good morning
welcome to reason means we will now open
the public hearing on Senate bill 112.
relative to Perry Mutual pools and
historic horse racing uh I only have one
pink card
um and it's not the prime sponsor do we
good morning and welcome uh recognizing
Maya uh I'm sorry is it Harvey thank you
uh who's here on behalf of senator
good morning chairman and members of the
Ways and Means Committee I am Maya
Harvey communications director of the
New Hampshire Senate and I'm joining you
today to introduce Senate Bill 112 on
behalf of senator asharti this bill
makes a few changes to RSA 284 the
amended version of this bill removes a
language that would extend the 40-mile
simulcasting buffer to Historic horse
racing facilities and removes language
that would allow simulcasting at
historic horse racing facilities by
removing section one and making a
housekeeping change to section 3.
additionally this bill repeals the
requirement of needing 70 of employees
at a racing facility to be New Hampshire
residents with no live racing this is
unneeded
I'd be happy to take any questions but
please note I will need to defer
responses to senator rashardi who I will
have follow-up I also believe the
Lottery Commission may have
representation here today to take any
thank you you just opened yourselves up
representative Platt has his hand up
yeah you won a 78 RPM and I type it 34
RPM do you have that what you gave
written please absolutely yes sorry
thank you yeah that was hard for me too
to even get all the elements
um representative only yes I kind of uh
blocked it the first one did you say
removes a buffer
yes so the amended version removes the
language that would extend the 40 mile
simulcasting buffer to Historic horse
um I do not have the bill in front of me
but I can have Senator ricciardi follow
up
but you're saying as amended it removed
that is that what you're saying so the
amended version does remove that
language
could you would you
since we all seem to have a lot of
questions could you go over that one
more time yes it's a little bit slow
more slowly so we understand all the
elements thank you and then we'll do
questions is it representative just a
quick clarification I believe that
what she's saying is that she's giving a
list of the changes the amended bill
made to the bill as introduced and so
that section for example on
the 40 mile perimeters
is not in this
because it was deleted in the amendment
thank you right so you are yeah if you
could just read that more slowly so we
understand your the amended version does
what thank you so this bill is making a
few representative Ami yeah do you have
something that tells us what's in the in
the bill is amended I'm sure I can have
we do have the amended Bill though right
we don't have their explanation of it
uh of the parts that weren't amended
okay well we're not going to overly
Grill you but we would love to hear what
you have to say just a little more
yeah
Maya go ahead and just one more time so
we can hear you better yes
um so this bill makes a few changes to
RSA 284.
the amended version of this bill removes
the language that would extend the
40-mile simulcasting buffer to Historic
horse racing facilities
it also removes language that would
allow similar casting at historic horse
racing facilities by removing section
one and it makes a housekeeping change
does that make sense okay thank you very
much what was section one that it
removed
okay you know what she's here on behalf
of the senator and why don't we uh give
her a break if you any questions that
you have I'm going to go back and write
them down for Senator ricciardi so I can
make sure that everyone's um you know
inquiries are followed up with thank you
so much yeah we'll we'll get some more
testimony from other folks but thank you
representative ulery
yeah thank you and thank you for
representing representing the center
that doesn't make any sense
a couple of questions you can ask her
um regarding the background checks which
uh
um
would take place if you're allowing the
interstate
um employees
do the in perhaps the commissioner can
answer this at some time do the
background checks include
uh a Nick's check or is it just a New
Hampshire check because the New
Hampshire check is only New Hampshire so
if you've got a person residing another
state they don't really
fall into the system this is something
that shows up with
um for example a sexual predators below
often move from state to state to state
to avoid that because most background
checks are only the state of residence
and the second thing is the 100 percent
odd sense of the breakage coming across
um
is this in addition to the general fund
Monies
that would go into the the gambling and
treat uh treatment to fund
or is this the solely fund that that
area
okay thank you very much thank you
another question for Senator
yes on I am producing an amendment which
would put the breakage into a dedicated
fund because I looked in the dedicated
funds book and there is nothing under
Lottery that uh is a problem gaming fund
and I I would like to know if that's any
kind of a problem for them
and for
the commit the executive director
thank you thank you very much okay so uh
next up we have Rick Newman uh Lakes
morning Madam chair and members of the
committee thank you for hearing me I'll
be very brief I hope
um my name is Rick Newman and I am here
on behalf of Lakes Region Casino which
is one of two facilities in New
Hampshire that are eligible to have
simulcast racing they don't have it
right now the brook is the only one that
does have it but under our current law
uh Belmont also is eligible
and I'm speaking just I think there are
unintended consequences with this bill
relative to the breakage section uh when
we were in the Senate
it was brought up I think by Lottery
actually that the language May
adversely impact some historic horse
racing uh manufacturers I was not aware
of that at that time it's come to my
attention that that is potentially a
problem so I I would recommend that the
bill be retained I think it is basically
a technical Corrections bill I don't
think there are any earth-shattering
provisions in it and nothing that
couldn't be put off for the six months
that retaining it would do one thing I
would like to point out I think it was I
forget who brought it up perhaps
representative ulrey but
um currently for instance the brook
keeps 50 percent of breakage this bill
would change that so they keep none of
it it would all go to to the state in
some form that of course would apply to
Lakes Region Casino where they too get
into go back to simulcasting which I
think is a disincentive there isn't a
lot of money not a lot of profit in
simulcasting and uh having uh taking
away this one incentive that might
encourage them at one point or another
to go back into the business I think is
a is not necessarily a good move so I
think that whole section on the breakage
issue itself needs to be carefully
looked at to make sure we're not doing
something that we didn't intend to do
thank you could you just point out which
section so we can find sure um so if you
look at the bill
talking about uh
it really begins in
section one of the bill
uh
and it also continues into section two
those
in section three those three sections uh
address changes to the language that
that governs what breakage is and how
I'll just point out one one quick thing
for you if you if you look at it right
now
um
the language that defines what breakage
is look at page
uh one line
or 17.
so right now under the current law the
language says
uh based on each dollar wagered this
bill
uh changes that to say
of each wager apparently there may be
some unintended consequence to that
language I'm not clear exactly what it
is I'm simply saying I think it's
something we should be looking at a
little more carefully which is why I
for some reason when I read this I was
focused on the employee state residency
thing can you talk to that I don't know
what what is that yeah so that's what's
really a throwback to the days of live
racing um when uh I I think that may
have been put in when dog racing was
approved at Seabrook and uh you know the
legislature wanted to make sure that New
Hampshire residents got priority at
those jobs and so there were a lot of
those jobs where people that worked in
the paddock and you know stewards and
those sorts of things and of course we
don't have any live racing in New
Hampshire now and I can't say there
never will be but I doubt very much if
someone is going to do the expense of
building a track to have live racing
anywhere so it really is something that
would you be open to other questions
sure thank you representative
thank you um
mine three of Page Three uh right after
that on
why are we repealing the requirement for
annual financial statements
uh so that
financial statement again it the current
law refers to a racing plant I believe
it is and again I think that's uh
really was intended to be alive live
racing it's it was never it's not clear
that it so again it's a redundant
statute that doesn't need to be there
thank you
representative
microphone please I'm sorry thank you
you brought up the um issue with
breakage and unintended consequences so
I'm going to tell you how I read this
part and see if this is matches what
your concern was that the current
language
and breakage is the the pennies the
difference
um the second decimal when you look at
an amount of money so it's it's the you
know it's not 10 it's like one through
nine on the end so
um the way it's written now
if there's a bet of ten dollars
and the payout or whatever you want to
call that is
like 1.2 dollars in nine cents
that right now you take that nine cents
and you'd it would be times ten because
the wager was ten dollars so that would
be 90 cents and if the way it's worded
now
it doesn't say per dollar it's per wager
so that ten dollar wager would deliver
whatever it was you know um ten dollars
and 90 cents in which case there's no
breakage is that the way you're looking
foreign
as I understand I mean breakage today
the way it's the way the law is written
now in your example if once we've
distributed the winnings to all of the
winners if it comes to two dollars and
nine cents each winner would get two
dollars nine cents is breakage that goes
into the breakage money which is then
distributed currently half is cut by the
state half by the uh facility
um
I really can't answer the question you
specifically asked but I think that is
another reason why I think maybe the
bill should be retained
all right we'll just keep going around
this side I see a hand up yes
representative Jordan ulery
oh thank you madam chair what which
representative helps brings up a
interesting question
um
in here it just says which is breakwood
which is called breakage
uh
the redistribution of each wage
exceeding some equal to the next lowest
multiple of 10 is known as breakage now
it's not 10 cents but it's 10 so if if
you were payout 10.90
you would pay out the uh
it does not now it does not now it does
not know
Madam chair
then please explain to us how breakage
Works currently so that we all have the
same
starting point
well I hope I can but um if you if the
if if after we have money in a prize
pool Lloyd paramutual wagering Works
money goes into a pull
okay so we have X dollars in the in the
wind pool okay okay then we have a
certain number of people who have the
winning ticket
okay that those number of winners is
divided by the number of money into the
winpool and that money is distributed to
or that's what they call the
redistribution that's distributed to the
winners if that calculation comes to
something other than the dime if it
comes to three dollars and
11 cents per person each of those people
get 310 and the penny is the breakage if
it comes to 330 per person each of those
people get 330 and there would be no
okay so it's to the it's to the 10th
decimal parts to the decimal not to the
dollar
correct
second that second does representative
all me
I was just going to suggest that we
ought to discuss these things with
Valerie King
I don't have any pink cards from our
friends from New Hampshire lottery but
hopefully they'll be willing to educate
us later today uh any questions on this
yeah just to follow and how much does uh
just
so we have some idea you say it's 50 50
currently what does that account to the
state how much to the uh game operator
um I think it's about seventy thousand
dollars
it's about seventy thousand dip if you
if this bill passes the state would I
believe receive
seventy thousand more dollars than they
do today
less dollars than they do today Lottery
would increase by 105. yeah lottery so
if you include Lottery if you so the
right now the the brook in La last year
the brook received approximately seventy
thousand dollars or cap seventy thousand
dollars in breakage
that would now go to the lottery and
follow up one more on his
follow-up on your comment regarding
incentive to in your case uh Lakes
Region six region Casino
um not seventy thousand dollars is not a
small sum for the types of operations we
have in this state is that correct
that's correct that's a significant
amount of money there is not a lot of
thank you
thank you very much and I should
probably mention that I am in this
industry
um I'm not sure if I'm impacted by this
bill but I am in this industry okay we
also have a card from Peter Bragdon
representing Churchill drown Churchill
virtual trout
welcome back Senator thank you madam
chair members of the committee for the
record Peter bragden a senior policy
advisor with pretty strategies uh here
today representing Churchill Downs uh
Churchill Downs in addition to owning
the Chasers Poker Room in Salem also uh
owns and operates Gaming facilities in
10 states and have been involved with
the design of historic racing machines
used across the country and due to some
recent acquisitions is now in the
business of manufacturing such machines
and really have no uh objections to any
of the the bill in in the grand scheme
of the intent of the bill but have some
some specific concerns uh with one piece
of the bill that would be on page two
uh section three which starts on line 25
and this kind of piggybacks on with the
discussion you folks were having about
breakage
with the historic racing machines
breakage Works in a similar way although
it's not it's not split with the
machines 100 of the breakage goes uh for
problem gaming none of it is retained by
The Operators uh the concern that's been
expressed to me by my client and uh I
don't fully understand the details but
based on how this is written in this
case changing the redistribution based
on each dollar wagered to be
redistribution based on each wager uh
the machines are not programmed uh or
their Hardware is not set in such a way
as it can compute that it works the way
it is now but there's some concern that
by changing this language has the
possibility of making it so that they
can't compute that value we have no
objection to paying the breakage
um and it's really on a matter of time
we calculate it with the technology that
we currently have in the machines that
are in operation I do think sometime
would lend itself to resolving this
issue and would request that the bill
either be retained or some work sessions
on it and there are some options there
uh either keeping the status quo
language or even if it was you know some
percentage some calculation in statute
that said this is what breakage should
be that would be fine too so it's not an
objection to paying the breakage it's
more of objection to the machines may
not be able to calculate the breakage if
this particular change is made
happy to answer any questions thank you
uh Rosa only
of each wager means and so could you
walk us through it
um I don't really although as it was
explained to me at least with some of
the machines out there a person puts a
wager in let's say let's say a dollar
just for round numbers and I don't know
if that's realistic or not
um
that is broken up between actually three
separate races that are run and so now
it's no longer one bet it's three
separate bets
um and so under the way the law
currently stands it can be calculated
based on that one bet but internally
it's broken down into three separate
bets and my understanding is the
machines don't have the ability once
that money is fed in the slot to
determine what the actual breakage is at
that granular level
put across three races so that's and I
have a minor in mathematics and a major
in computer science so I assume somebody
could explain it to me so I got it but
it had something to do with the fact
that you're on some machines it's
actually spread across three races at a
time so that's the best I can do uh
represent me
thank you thank you follow up follow up
so you mean that the person has actually
bet on three different
races or horses within the internals of
the machine I believe that is actually
what's happening
thank you
okay we'll start on this side and go
around the room representative Phyllis
just a technical follow-up So when you
say three races is that win place and
show or is it no I have a very easy
answer for that I don't know
[Laughter]
representative
time no okay working around any
questions on this side of the room yes
representative spilsbury thank you madam
chair
it seems to me the primary purpose here
is to change the allocation the
distribution and I'm wondering
if all of the changes let's let's take
the first example where it comes up on
page one
lines 16 through 23.
if all of the changes in language there
were kept
but only the change
from based on each dollar wagered to of
each waiver if that was removed and
everything else was left intact
um thank you for the question I'm not
sure all the other sections where this
appears relates to the simulcast and
doesn't apply to any historic racing
machines which is my area of Interest so
I'm not sure how it would affect those
uh to be honest okay but that is
essentially what's repeated four times
during page one and two that is correct
thank you very much you're welcome
okay and uh Valerie King and or Charlie
McIntyre have also filled out a pink
card hopefully they can help explain
breakage
good morning my name is Valerie King I
oversee the enforcement and compliance
division over at New Hampshire Lottery
uh Charlie McIntyre directory would you
be able to explain breakage in a way
that we could maybe understand it sorry
that's me
um actually Rick did a good job of it
it's when you have when when the payout
has an extra uh pennies it doesn't round
out to a dime so if like Rick said if
it's three dollars and 11 cents that
penny is breakage and it goes into a
separate pool a separate
piggy bank
other questions from the committee for
New Hampshire lottery yes representative
Phillips
so thank you so my take of this that
that's what I thought the breakage was
I'm just I'm just working on the
calculation because I know math I don't
know gambling
um that if you were to make your bet if
you're not going to calculate that
breakage for each dollar of the bet that
was made and you're going to calculate
it on the total for the BET every time
the bet is
ten dollars
you're not going to get any breakage
Therefore your revenue is going to be
significantly lower from that breakage
so I I think that the issue is
The Wager may be less than a dollar
and so when it's less than a dollar
there would be no breakage but when it's
more than a dollar there would be
breakage so in this case you're changing
it so now it's any wager before it was
it has to be a dollar or more now it can
be any wager which means that 10 cent
wager that you put on a historic horse
so I'm not understanding why is is a
dollar the largest wager you can make
no
it can be less on a historic horse
racing machine it can be less
it can be more it can be less
so if the wager is
ten dollars
it then there is no breakage
no it depends on the amount of the wind
not the amount of the bet for breakage
all right I understand that but the
basic when the when the amount
per dot currently the amount per dollar
for a win is
is a number that's one dollar rounded to
do well it's rounded to two decimals
if that's correct when your 10 when you
have a ten dollar bet that second
decimal is always going to be zero but
maybe that's not what happens so if
that's not how it is tell me I think
you're mixing two things this is saying
that you you wouldn't even calculate
breakage if the if the wager that you
wagered was less than a dollar currently
if it's less than a dollar there's
there's no breakage calculation if it's
more than a dollar wager then breakage
does apply
it's not talking about the penny part
it's talking about when when breakage
okay we're gonna keep going around the
room representative Southworth I thank
you for taking my question so to follow
up what is the advantage of the change
both in terms of the business and the
state or the Lottery Commission there
must be an advantage I think the
ultimate Advantage I think of the
question representative was to increase
the funding for problem gaming
um which not just increases the funding
but also this has to apply to the budget
as well annually there's a quarter
million dollars applied to problem
gambling out of our budget and this
would be the one of the revenue sources
so I just want to clarify something you
just said because representative only
had a question so you already have 250
000 in a problem gaming fund is it a
dedicated fund
I'm taking the question Madam chair it's
a the council is administratively
attached to us which has a very specific
definition under the law we don't
oversee them they are an independent
body that is a okay administratively
tied to us we assist them in matters of
procurement finances
um we they use our facilities for their
meetings that kind of thing so but also
they receive 250 000 which they are
independently responsible for
thank you so much representative did you
wanna
I think we're on a different tact right
now but on the Council of problem gaming
on doesn't have a dedicated fund if it's
administratively attached because I was
looking at the dedicated fund book and
it's not named no it's literally
contained within our budget as an
expense essentially the lottery
essentially the lottery right and
there's no
um
there's they don't have to use governor
and Council
which we've run into with another bill
that uh fish and game has to go to
governor and Council for all of the
money of the endangered species
fund because it's not a dedicated fund
yet so they're becoming a dedicated fund
I don't know the answer that question
yeah
representative Jordan ulery
um thank you madam chair and thank you
commissioner
being administratively attached to the
lottery
that means that you have to take from
your budget X number of dollars to for
that entity
if this money were to go into let's say
we set up a dedicated fund which would
reduce your budget by x amount
uh which would go in whatever we put
into that the question then comes as to
how much you're now spending for problem
gaming via the commission
and
would this generate more or less
than that amount
and
what a cap on receipt of this amount
meet both the the incentive
um
portion of this as well as provide uh
non-general fund funding for the
commission
okay I understand your question you're
asking regarding the funds and the
Council on the commission
historically the legislature is assigned
us tasks to do and made us pay for it
and so
um this is no different and so this is
literally an expense of ours that comes
out of our existing operating budget If
This Were to pass then this funds the
additional funds would
supplant money we currently expend and
then the supplanted funds would then
drop to the bottom line is return to
education profit because that's in terms
of the Constitution it's very simple
revenues minus expenses equals return
education so and honestly thirty five
thousand dollars on what this year will
be 180 million dollars in profit is a
follow-up
okay that didn't answer the other
question about putting a cap on the
amount of funds to go back to the game
operator as an incentive to continue to
operate the game oh I understand
um
that's one for the operators in terms of
what you would assess them is is it
incentive obviously
there were two facilities that had a
right to have simulcast one was in
Hinsdale one Still Remains in Belmont
obviously when Hinsdale doesn't operate
anymore so that would give you
indication of of its
profitability
okay
um why don't I go this way and we'll go
back around represent a plat
yes
um
it's pretty clear to understand
the argument by Rick Newman doesn't want
to pay when it comes to keep 50 instead
of 100 I understand that and you're
disagreeing because you need the money
no no it's we this wasn't our bill we
didn't okay no this wasn't not disagree
representative yeah okay do you
understand Peter bragan's point about
not being able to calculate you and to
get into weeds enough to understand
where they have trouble with that
um so the the question because this is
relates to simulcast yeah I think he was
conflating that with historic horse
racing machines which has a separate
breakage calculation as I understand it
okay
so so the HHR is a problem for them
they're not simultaneous so the language
specific to breakage in this
Bill relates to simulcast breakage which
is different than breakage on a historic
horse racing machine okay
unless there's some connection that I'm
not aware of they're two different laws
okay keep going around this side yes
representative thank you madam chair
um I'm looking at the fiscal note and
everybody's getting their papers out
um
the indication here is that there would
be a seventy thousand dollar annual
decrease in the general fund and 105 000
increase going to the lottery but on the
funding source it says general education
and other
so I'm wondering what that education
refers to
um thank you for the question
representative it's essentially because
our funding is education that's why
that's checked all right so it would not
be coming out of no no no what the
opposite okay thank you thank you madam
chair
okay we're working around the room
anything over here
representative fellows
I just want to ask the commissioner if
you if we look at the total
pot there are two parts related to
breakage one is how you're going to
split up the money for breakage and the
other one is how you're going to
calculate breakage differently so let's
just talk about just calculating it
differently
so right now
um I think it says in the fiscal note
um the total amount
for breakage from
2022 calendar year was a hundred and
forty thousand dollars
so if we calculate
breakage differently
do you think that will affect what the
total amount is going to be of course
it's you know it's not going to be 140
again but you know does that have any
so my guess is probably not only because
most simulcast Wagers are more than a
dollar so the the change from any wage
or two
um any uh wager of a dollar or more
follow up
so get back to my original question that
I asked you I asked you about the
difference I asked you about when a
wager was ten dollars and you didn't
respond to that you just told me about
wages less than a dollar
so do how do you tell me what the
breakage looks like on a wager of ten
dollars versus the way we calculate it
now on one dollar and then time you know
as if it were 10 Wagers
um so yes so that's your question ten
dollars would just be a multiple of one
in that case and would
award you 10 times more than if one
person had been a dollar of that
available prize pool so that would be
one more follow-up
so if there was
if on if on the one dollar wager the
return was a dollar and nine cents
yes then you have nine cents of breakage
correct and if it's if you're going to
calculate the breakage on the amount of
the wager which is my reading of this
bill a ten dollar wager would be
ten dollars and ninety cents not correct
and no breakage
so I'm not sure when you make a wager
it's all depending upon how many other
people made Wagers and so you can't
calculate the breakage based on a
individual weight what is it
breakages from the winnings and so when
you place a wager and you win if you and
it might make it easier to know the
history that in the old days when the
window people had to pay out your wager
they didn't want to deal with the
pennies
so they wouldn't pay you the pennies
they they'd leave that behind and all
that extra money went into a separate
pot
but what so what is a wager do are we
just how much you bet ten ten dollars
ten dollars is your wager but it it does
not necessarily cut you don't make a
calculation of breakage on the wager
that's what this bill says to do you
know what it's saying is when the wager
is less than a dollar
then they don't we don't get any partial
okay
did you do you have a question
yeah okay follow up on what
the was just said by represented fellows
there's a difference and you pointed it
out there's a difference between wager
which is the money I give
and winnings which is the money
the operator gives
the breakage is based upon what the
operator gives
okay so it's not based on the wager
right it's based on the winnings right
so the award wager in here changes that
based on the amount of money I give
so if we change it to winnings now we're
talking about how much money is coming
back to me is that what you were trying
to say
yeah I like the way you put it uh folks
I'm thinking this would be nice because
we have a lot of folks here for the next
bill that maybe we do a work session on
this if you'd be open to joining us so
we can better understand it that be yes
representative
yes I think also we ought to pursue the
senator and find out why she wanted to
change the language of it of each wave
to of each wager well she happens to be
my Senator so I will happily reach out
thank you so much
okay I do not have any more ping cards
on Senate Bill 112 is there anyone else
seeing none we will close the public
yes it was confusing okay moving right
along we will now open up the public
hearing on Senate Bill more stuff
Senate bill 104.
FNA and for the record I am involved in
this industry I have some things coming
around here hold on did you get a copy
of these
I just did not okay
yeah please give us a moment while we
okay let's try to do this hi welcome
back
chair recognizes Senator Tim Lang to
introduce Senate Bill 104. thank you
madam chair thank you members of the
committee my name is Senator Tim Lang I
represent District 2 which is if I go
back to my old New Jersey days it's
exit 20 to Exit 29 on the east side of
the interstate
um is my General District
um I I'm presenting you uh how a Senate
Bill 104
um
so many of you know I I'm the chair of
the Senate Ways and Means Committee in
addition I've served three terms on in
the house and on this committee
um so charitable gaming is something I'm
fairly familiar with however the
interesting thing about this bill is
that I came at it backwards
so I didn't come in because I wanted to
legalize online gaming I came in because
I wanted to provide a solution to our
Workforce problem
and using our community college system
as a way to get there however I'm a
pragmatic person and I won't present a
bill that's going to have a cost unless
I know where that cost is coming from
as we all know that the budget's
strained as it is where we choose to
spend our money so I came up with a new
Revenue stream using online gaming to be
able to help solve some of our Workforce
issues
so I'll talk first about the online
gaming so the online gaming piece is
just simply that it allows for eye
gaming only table games so no electronic
games no HHR no Lucky Seven none of
those games that we allow in the brick
and mortar uh component it allows
strictly poker Blackjack roulette those
kind of games to be able to play online
one of the reasons why I look at this
bill as as a good bill is in in that
environment the online game you can go
right now to bovada.lv which is based
out of Costa Rica put money into your
account and start playing poker however
if you win there is no obligation and no
mechanism for you to actually get your
money
and the reason for that is you have no
consumer protections you can't exactly
go to the attorney general and say hey I
was illegally playing poker out of a
site out of Costa Rica and I won the
jackpot and they're refusing to pay me
you have no no mechanism to do that
whatsoever because you have to be
admitting to a crime in the state of New
Hampshire if you did that and so the
bill bill allows forced consumer
protections it protects our citizens who
choose to pay play online poker or
online blackjack or online roulette
those type of table games who choose to
play make their choice so that's where
they want to spend their money and it
gives them some consumer protections to
allow them to be able to deal with the
fact that an illegal operator is in the
state and it gives you them the ability
to go to the attorney general and say
this is an illegal operator playing in
our state that shouldn't be playing and
gives the Attorney General the ability
to prosecute and go after them so for
breaking New Hampshire law which is that
you have to be an authorized agent to
play online poker authorized by the
state so so consumer protection was a
big part of this bill
the bill was amended in the in the
Senate twice the first part because they
completely forgot OLS in a drafting
error completely forgot to put the RFP
process in the bill on how we'll select
our vendors and how Lottery will do that
so the first amendment in the ways of
Means Committee in the Senate was to add
that RFP process back in that literally
it was a cut and paste error and fixed
that the second part has to do with the
community college scholarship fund
um so when I talk so we have the online
gaming consumer protections and that's
what I'm authorizing people are doing
this already we saw with sports betting
um you know which I was the Prime
sponsor of as well to allow online
sports betting and in-person sports
betting
um that generated 67 or now I think it's
over 70 million dollars to education
since that bill was passed in 2019. so
online services allow for an opportunity
for us to to create revenue on a
voluntary basis nobody's forced to do
either sports betting and they'll be
forced to do online gaming create a
revenue stream to fix our Workforce
problem so I'm going to step into the
workforce problem now I think we've all
seen that New Hampshire has a
significant Workforce issue in that go
try to find an electrician a plumber a
carpenter go go to a hospital and ask
them what their needs are for nurses
phlebotomists Radiology techs every one
of those jobs I just cited let's do one
more let's go to the education and look
at early childhood development special
education right again all of those jobs
I just mentioned can be provided by the
community college system at a faster
rate than a four-year college so instead
of waiting four years for a student to
step out of as K-12 go into college and
come back out instead of waiting four
years we move the workforce up by two
years by providing funding one of the
one of the titles I give this bill is
the jobs the careers bill so my goal is
to take people who are in part-time
low-income jobs who may have a financial
burden at the financial
barrier to getting an education and
provide a funding mechanism so this bill
not only supports credited courses but
uncredited courses so the community
college system has a great coders boot
camp for cyber security and it would
allow while some grants like I believe
the Pell Grant doesn't support those
kind of programs because it has to be
accredited program that gets actual
college credits towards a degree this
program would allow for those certified
certification programs that are
available in our community college
system so even if you're not leading to
an associate's degree but you're leading
to get a career certification enter into
a degree you could use the funding from
the community college scholarship on
that's created by this bill to be able
to support that in the nursing industry
you look at there are some significant
lab fees for some of those jobs when you
take those courses and some of those
fees are not covered labs and books are
not covered necessarily by Grant
programs this would allow a student who
would otherwise want to go into that
program but the 500 lab fee becomes a
cash barrier for them would allow them
to enter in so that person is working
that part-time job McDonald's Walmart
pick your pick your corporation of
choice who's trying to move from a
part-time you know low-income job to a
higher wage job like a a two-year RN
right for our nursing industry would
free up the barriers to allow them to be
able to go into that into those
educational opportunities and saw New
Hampshire's Workforce problem and give
us workers in a really short period of
time to solve some of our issues again
carpentry electrician are line workers
for
um for our electric companies all of
these are types of jobs and careers high
paying careers I'll mind you that are
available out of the community college
system so as part of the other
negotiation I did as this is that we had
a conversation with the university
system of New Hampshire but they felt
left out
and so we were looking to support the
university system New Hampshire as well
but related to a way of keeping again
students in the state of New Hampshire
so if a student was to complete their
associate's degree at the community
college system and then decided they
were going to go on to a four-year
degree how can we encourage them to take
the rest of their four-year degree in
the state of New Hampshire so what this
bill does is it allows a cooperation
effort between the community college
system and the university system so that
if a student graduates from the two-year
college and and is applying to four-year
colleges and they apply to UNH and they
apply let's say the University of Maine
it turns out the University of Maine is
cheaper than UNH it would allow the
community college system to basically
Grant a gap funding and pay it so that
the out-of-pocket for that person going
to UNH would be the same as if they went
to UMaine and allows that person to stay
for the remaining third and fourth year
of their education cycle uh college
education cycle to stay in New Hampshire
and we know that people are educated in
New Hampshire and do their internships
in New Hampshire are more likely to stay
in New Hampshire so again this is uh the
idea to keep New Hampshire students in
New Hampshire to help our Workforce I'm
happy to take questions I know there's
going to be a whole lot of conversation
about because I've saw the emails they
were sent to me about cannibalization
are we going to cannibalize our
Charities and our charity is going to
lose money
understand this the Senate looked at all
the bills that you'll have and I think
I'm going to be your friend for the next
two days I think I have seven bills I'm
introducing over the next two days in
this committee
um all of those bills we looked at the
charitable gaming bills as a large
policy we didn't look it through a straw
of just 104. right we looked at we
looked at House Bill 607 which you guys
sent over to us we looked at Senate Bill
120 which you have as well as Senate
Bill 51 and a few others you have and we
looked holistically including the one
you just heard Senate Bill 112 which
deals with breakage and sending that to
the problem gaming fund recognizing
we're expanding gaming there may be in
more need of funding and so therefore we
looked at this holistically as all these
bills together as a as a charitable
gaming policy what it's doing when it
comes to cannibalization they'll hear
all kinds of Statistics one of them will
talk about New Jersey that lost Revenue
in the brick and mortar casinos however
if you normalize that data and what I
mean by that is they're comparing two
years one year that has
um
X number of casinos and the next year
they have x minus two because two of
them went bankrupt and they went
bankrupt before online gaming went
online but they went bankrupt
um and therefore obviously you're going
to see a reduction in revenues with a
bankrupt organization bankrupt uh Casino
the next year's revenue is going to be
lower but if you normalize that out back
out to so we have x equals x so we we
normalize the data you'll see there was
no loss to the brick and mortar
Charities when New Jersey put online
gaming in place
um
the last thing I'll talk about is the
Charities we again you've I've got an
email about about how this is going to
hurt Charities but remember we passed
house you guys passed House Bill 607
that raised the Wagers from ten dollars
to twenty five dollars and we'll hear
later in the in either today or tomorrow
remember where the bill is but about a
bill I put forward that raises it to
fifty dollars so that raising of the of
the Wagers and the and the tournament
Stakes are going to dramatically
increase the amount of Revenue going to
Charities again we looked at this
holistically to make sure everybody was
taken care of in negotiations with
um with director McIntyre in this bill
uh he agreed to
um doing again it's an app on your phone
and there'll be an advertising space so
we're going to advertise the brick and
mortise based on your geolocation if
you're in the state of New Hampshire it
will tell you where your closest brick
and mortar is if you don't want to play
online and you want to play against
human beings at a table it'll show you
where your closest brick and mortar is
to to encourage if you want to go play
and you want to take it from Just online
to in person where your closest places
to go play so again the Charities will
be served by that I'm happy to take
questions I know I talk fast and talked
representative fellows thank you madam
chair
um representative Senator Lang my
Senator thank you
um I mentioned to you last week that in
the state constitution it says that
Lottery
money should be used exclusively for
school districts in the state so had you
have you had any time to look into that
and can you respond to
um if you agree with that and
also would you probably possibly be
amenable to changing where the profits
go to put it in the to direct it to
school districts it would go into the
education trust fund
thank you for your question so I'll take
that I'll take it to two parts of that
question so the first was the
constitutionality of moving it moving
the money into the um
into the community college system so you
have to go back and look at when that
when that constitutional amendment was
passed it was when New Hampshire passed
its first lottery so the question is it
Lottery as defined by the division that
executive director McIntyre runs desert
Lottery as defined by sweepstakes which
is what was implemented at the time that
um that Constitutional Amendment went in
so I view it as it speaks about lottery
in terms of the function not the
department so in this case we've already
decided that purposes of gaming that
Lottery can do charitable gaming and
that gaming which is managed by Lottery
goes to charities in this case so the
way I view it is no it's not a
constitutional prohibition
um I do I don't believe that I think if
we were trying to take Powerball money
and move that into some other function
yes I think that might be a problem
based on our constitution but in the
purposes of gambling I don't believe so
I think that's a different function
um in terms of your second question I
would prefer you not move the fund again
I was trying to solve a Workforce
problem I think we see we have an
acknowledged Workforce problem we know
how tight the state budget is
um the uh so I would not look at doing
that I think this solves a problem for
low-income families and and families
that are struggling to be able to
provide an educational opportunity
either for the child or maybe if it's a
parent that's looking to move out of a
low dead end job and move into a
different career and the goal of this
bill is to do that not just to dump more
okay great and just I want to keep
things moving because we have a lot of
pink cards on this and unless you want
to work all the way through lunch you
want to keep things moving to like quick
questions in three minutes if we need we
can do more later yes representative
self-worth
thank you for taking my question
um when I'm looking at the estimates
um about 7 million 2024 then 27 million
then 40 million for 2026.
um I just want to be clear where that
money is coming from this is gross
Gaming revenue uh that chart there I'm
just wondering
um are some people gambling more is it
cutting into other lottery programs it
just seems like you know it's an extra
34 million dollars that's coming from
somewhere
um and I know we keep making changes and
adding things but I'm just wondering
like what is where's that money actually
going to come from
great so I think your question is around
a Tipping Point right where is it where
does it start cannibalizing our own
Lottery revenues so again I think we saw
and I think Executive Director McIntyre
can answer this is again I'll go back to
sports betting which we implemented in
2019. it's generated over 70 million
dollars for the for education for the
education trust fund we didn't see
cannibalization the Powerball we didn't
see cannibalization into other areas of
of state-run Gaming I think that's the
only answer I can give you anything to
ask executive McIntyre the same question
the bottom line is just kind of
um there's more room in people gambling
more in New Hampshire I'd argue people
are already gambling in New Hampshire
and this just legalizes what they're
doing to bring Revenue to the state
representative Ames
yeah
this is first a question for you chair
um and that is whether this bill is a
second is going to a second committee
given that it raises issues of
allocation to a particular goes to a
second committee but I'm going to double
check that okay uh and I'm going to ask
my helpers here to double check go
online and double check but I don't
believe it is a second committee bill
yeah all right thank you
um
I guess on the uh uh you've you've
answered the question on the uh
constitutional issue that raised by
representative fellows and I think
that's an issue that needs to be
explored but I I don't want to take time
here exploring it uh with the witness
any further because he's answering full
okay thank you uh representative Olney
thank you I just wanted to get clear
because I was having trouble figuring
this out on page three on Section seven
starting on line 13. online gaming
um means everything that is being done
in person Now offline correct
in charitable gaming I'm sorry can you
repeat the question I can have a hard
time hearing you gaming means everything
that
um charitable gaming in person uh
on store um
sites are doing
but doing it online instead of offline
yes I think is the correct answer to
that question
yeah
other other questions get music
um thank you madam chair and thank you
senator for taking my question
um
I want to right now just focus on
finances rather than the
some of the other aspects of the bill
currently New Hampshire has the lowest
State support for public education in
the entire country
and while I absolutely support the
notion of community college students
getting support I'm wondering why we are
not
adding to the funding that we are
providing for
K through 12 or even preschool through
grade 12. education when we are the
lowest State support for public
education in the country
thank you very much
um so my other hat is I serve and I just
left the Senate education committee to
also serve on that committee as well and
this question came up as we were just
discussing efas
um so I I guess I'd answer to you is
that number New Hampshire is number two
number two in the nation
for the quality of Education provided
we're number 48 relative to the amount
of money the state provides for the
purposes of Education So my answer to
you is the two aren't linked right we
can provide a quality good education As
proved by the number two rating that we
have in our state for the quality
education that we provide and at the
same point be cost efficient so
uh
follow up let me just remind the members
that we're not here to debate with the
uh with any sponsor or person testifying
we are here to ask clarifying questions
thank you representative Albert thank
you madam chair
the remainder of the money that goes to
public education comes out of local
property taxes correct
thank you
thank you senator
I think that's it for now we'll move
along uh we have the chancellor Mark
welcome to amazing means oh we have
someone with you plus one great and what
is your name please
okay
great thank you for coming I do have
your card thank you for being here
good morning and thank you for having us
here
not here to speak specifically to gaming
or anything other than our mission which
is Workforce and support for this state
creating opportunities for New Hampshire
students of any age to participate in
their communities and Workforce and the
Civic life of this state
as Senator Lang described our students
are not typically traditionally students
the majority of our students are
part-time typically working adults
although they represent a cross-section
of of the population our objective is to
find ways to help them engage and again
as the senator described credit programs
non-credit shorter term certificate
programs things that are more directly
engaged with the workforce like lnas and
medical assistants and so forth but
nurses and paramedics welders and
Automotive technicians cyber security
folks the range of programs that we
offer aligns with the needs of this
state and our effort is simply to
support the opportunities for students
to help them engage this year I want to
say the house has been very kind to the
community college system in support from
the budget that's been passed gives us
an opportunity to provide those
opportunities Provide support for a
broad cross-section of the students we
seek to serve from high school through
dual enrollment all the way through
their careers but we're also mindful of
the fact that the states always facing
challenges for Revenue
Senators bill has potential to provide a
funding source that ironically becomes
more stable when the state's revenues
May contract if the economy falters at a
time when students will have greater
need for opportunities to transition
into new careers new opportunities as
their lives change in the needs of the
states change so again not in a position
to speak knowingly about gambling my
mother will be grateful but here to
speak primarily about our mission as a
resource for the state and its
communities to strengthen the workforce
and create opportunities for New
Hampshire
thank you and I would just add you know
Senator Lang mentioned a lot about that
the skill the one-year two-year
certificate credentials but also on the
non-credit we call it the upskilling
side of things so CDL training I would
add to that you know we need more of
these folks out there and what I would
just simply add is this provides a
revenue stream that would allow for a
place we do not currently have one uh
you know we talked about books or fees
additionally but a lot of the folks who
are looking to upskill make it
impossible for them to stop and do some
of this training the upskilling without
being eligible for Aid or other
scholarships so this would provide that
Revenue stream to again put people right
to work right out into the workforce
and we welcome your questions
representative Phyllis do you currently
have any programs that provide financial
assistance to the part-time adult
student and you know maybe the ones that
are looking for their certificates as
opposed to you know your your general
we we do have some resources in some
cases this is federal financial aid for
students who are half time or at least
half time we also have a significant
support through New Hampshire charitable
foundation for specific opportunities
working with the charitable foundation
and DHHS on a pilot program at
Manchester Community College for Ben
beneficiaries of the snap program so we
have peace pieces of that puzzle but not
supplemental nutritional assistance
program I believe is the uh the acronyms
source
representative only did you have a
question
okay uh questions over here
uh representative ORS
thank you madam chair and thank you for
taking my question so can you give us an
example of somebody that you've helped
that was in a low paying job whatever
non-skilled and you've brought them into
a skilled job that provides for our you
know helps our communities whether it's
electrician plumber hairdresser whatever
sure I'd love to take this one we've
actually got some students uh so I'm at
White Mountains Community College in the
North Country we have a location uh
Berlin North Conway Littleton I was in
Littleton just last week and uh you know
we have some students who their family
owns a truck dad has been the truck
driver
wife and daughter are now coming through
the CDL program so they can all rotate
because there was a limit of the number
of hours you can drive in a truck so now
the entire family is able to drive that
truck and they'll be purchasing a new
one so now not only do they have a you
know a great income stream to be able to
contribute back but also they are now
running two trucks and now they're able
to meet the needs of you know they pick
up loads and go back and forth so they
were not eligible for financial aid
however because of the income of the
father so what they do is they are
seeking scholarships or they're paying
it out of pocket right now so it takes a
little longer that to me is just one
small example of literally thousands of
them
thank you sure
thank you very much appreciate your
coming today
okay the chair will now recognize uh The
Honorable John Graham
thank you madam chair members of the
committee
um by way introduction I am John Graham
I live in Bedford
um I served a couple of years in this
body
um and I have been watching Senate Bill
104 as it went through its various
iterations
and I don't think anybody in the
University system or the community
college system can say that I was not
supportive when I was a member of this
body
for funding for those two institutions
because I am and I am supportive of the
idea of the grants and other things that
are contained in this bill I just think
that this is not the way to fund it
I believe that there's only so much
money available for wage rate when I
look at the fiscal note and I see 40
million dollars being wagered online
in the estimate in 2026 that's going to
come from some place I know that Senator
Lang said that with uh online Sports
gaming we didn't cannibalize anything
but at the same time we we tweaked uh
how much could be wagered at the brick
and mortar places and we also introduced
historic horse racing so you know you
got to put all these things together I
think that there will be a dilution of
what the Charities were able to get out
of the brick and mortar if we start
taking 40 million dollars a year
additional online gaming it's going to
come from someplace
um I belong to three bedford-based
non-uh prophets all of which use
charitable gaming to supplement their
budgets and I do mean supplement let me
give you one example the Bedford
American Legion Post which we don't have
a building we don't have a bar or any of
this stuff to raise money
um
last year 2022 we took in about twenty
two thousand dollars from charitable
gaming
however we gave out over eighteen
thousand dollars in scholarships over
ten thousand dollars to support two
American Legion Baseball teams three
thousand for students to attend
um residential programs in local and
state government run by the American
Legion and at approximately two thousand
dollars to support local veterans plus
the New Hampshire veterans home and the
residents at the VA so you see we spent
more that we took in from charitable
gaming I think that that's true of most
of the Charities if not all of the
Charities that are getting the money
so there is more than just a fiscal note
there is more than just what is going to
go to the educational system both um
the university system and primarily of
course the community college system I
think that the holistic approach that
the senator talked about is probably
skewed to the
um what they wanted in the Senate and
the house needs to take a different and
more in-depth uh look I would ask that
you find this bill in experiential
legislate I don't think you're going to
resolve the issue of what
is BET how it is BET what is going to be
taken away from the Charities what is
going to go into which pot of money
um with a single bill so I ask that you
find it in experience legislate and
I will try to answer any questions I am
fairly familiar I've been working on
charitable gaming since its Inception
decades ago thank you
thank you representative any questions
for the representative
representative Lloyd oh and I forgot to
introduce representative Lloyd is here
she's substituting for representative
liply today yes yes
um and bear with me because number one I
thank you madam chairman by the way
um I'm a freshman and uh number two I I
come from a non-profit background myself
um so I've been working in non-profit
Finance for 14 years now and I I
completely understand the concern about
making sure that we continue to fund our
um our Charities
um but I also truly appreciate the the
ability of this to create an education
um a a
a scholarship fund for higher education
that's much needed in this state
um my question I guess is how currently
and again I'm a sub
um how how much currently do we receive
for uh for charitable donations through
on through regular brick and mortar
gambling locations and is there any way
that we can come up with some sort of
provision to make sure that we still
provide our charitable organizations
what they're currently getting and then
the remainder goes to the education each
charity and the facility that they work
with provide a daily account of money
wagered money given to the charity money
kept um
by
um the the facility owner what with the
rent was so the lottery should be able
to roll up all of those from all of the
facilities across the state what was
wagered
um what went out to the Charities I know
that at one point
um a couple I don't remember how many
terms ago when we were talking about
um true casinos there was there was an
attempt to put in there that well we're
going to make whole the the Charities
um because it's going to suck the money
out of uh charitable gaming that came to
a very complicated and nobody truly
believed that it was going to last
beyond the first couple of years because
once you start getting the money in it's
up to succeeding
legislatures to decide where the money
goes it's nothing is permitted in this
building uh except when is uh prescribed
representative plan
um I heard from uh the sponsor Prime
sponsor Tim Lang
with some anecdote about New Jersey
instituted this and uh they didn't
really have a loss they lost a couple of
casinos but they were out before
charitable gaming so there's a point
that says there won't be
cannibalation cannibalization do you
have any specifics to point to to say
they would be no
um and I don't think you'll have any
until you actually start doing it and
then it's too late
um you know but if you just look at the
fiscal note again where it says in two
years you're going to be taking 40
million dollars of online Wagers
that 40 million is not all going to be
new Wagers it's going to be taken from
people who might have gone down to
um Boston Billiards uh the one in
Manchester
um the one in Keene wherever
um Tibet
I sincerely think that there will be
less done in the brick and mortar if I
can sit at home in my PJs and at bed
it's sort of like what we were doing
zooms and and remote work
um it's much easier because you don't
have to get up and and come to Concord
to do anything
I think that there will be a dilution of
what is BET at Brick and Mortar
um and no there's no way because we're
one of the few states that does the
charitable gaming if not the only one I
don't remember the way we do it where
the Charities partner with the facility
and get a portion of the proceeds for
their charitable uh work and
we tweaked it last year last term so
that with historic horse racing being
added to the mix that the the facility
now the same 10 days there are two
charities in in the facility sharing the
revenue that was part of the law
it did not affect too much the the
bottom line of what each charity was
getting but again they're not competing
online with anything
um so and and sports betting is also not
being done in these brick and mortar uh
charitable Gaming facilities so you know
you can't com uh compare the two of them
either
okay other hands up here representative
Doucette five thank you madam chair and
thank you for taking my question
representative Graham uh former
representative The Honorable John Graham
sorry
and I I realize you have some knowledge
uh in relation to charitable gaming and
the model that we have and you kind of
answered a few of the things I was going
to ask you in your discussion answering
uh representative plett's question uh
would you believe if I offer to you that
our present model in New Hampshire for
charitable gaming is unique in the
United States
I yeah I would believe that that's why
when I was just stumbling with with my
what I would say in a minute ago of if
if not the only one I I think that it is
uh but I wasn't going to categorically
say that without going back and checking
I would say we're safe to assume that
and and making comparisons to any other
state any other Casino gaming is not
comparing Apples to Apples oranges to
oranges
and it's the same as when
um Encore uh opened in Boston there was
concern that there would be a big draw
from our brick and mortar ones but
because it's more low stakes local it's
not the big players that go into you
know Salem OR or Seabrook or any of
those other places yeah they may go down
to Encore once in a while but they know
that the money is going into Charities
here in New Hampshire whether it be the
New Hampshire food bank I know that some
of them do that and and others and I'm
sure you'll hear from others who use the
money for for that kind of stuff and I
don't I know the Chairman's looking at
her watch going uh there are other
uh Pink cards I remember having to do
that
follow-up Man follow up yes and and
because of your experience in the
legislature going back historically
there was quite a tussle with big Casino
gaming and Us ending up with the model
that we have at present supporting the
Charities and supporting terrible gaming
so uh bear with me for a second we as a
legislature decided against big gaming
in this state yes we did and and truth
in advertising I always voted against uh
traditional casinos and a lot poor
reason for that was to maintain our
charitable gaming
um so that the Charities could do their
work in the local communities and not
hands over here is representative horse
thank you madam chair and thank you for
taking my question so I don't know if
you ever really answered representative
plett's question about having hardcore
examples but uh representative descent
just made an interesting comment and two
and you've responded with so if we
didn't lose
Gamers or whatever they're called to
Encore
might might we be getting more people
involved in gambling with with adding
like DraftKings or whatever it might be
and not be losing people to you know the
other Charities I personally I do not
think so
um we did not lose them because the
BET's down down there are much larger
when you have to go down when we have
five or ten dollars I think what is it
it's ten now
um
even at twenty dollars if you go to a a
major Casino where the the minimum bet
is twenty fifty hundred dollars on it on
a table you're not going to get the the
person like me who goes in with a group
of friends to play Blackjack
um at a couple dollars uh a hand
um and you're doing it for fun and
you're doing it because you know that
even if you lose the money is going to a
good place
thank you
thank you madam chair thank you nice to
see you uh okay the chair recognizes
oops I should replace my glasses Rebecca
Condon and Rich Parsons representing
DraftKings
and I have a sticky note from our
researcher Jennifer four I was incorrect
representative Ames uh we got these
bills really late for some reason so I
did not notice that this is an early
bill so Senate Bill 104 is an early bill
throughout May 11th
so
welcome Madam chair is that due out of
the house or do out of this commission
this committee
I have to go back to look at my notes I
think out of the committee but I'd have
okay out of this building I just never
couldn't remember the dates then that
would mean that May 18th we'd have to
vote it would be the deadline to vote on
thank you
good morning chair Sanborn and members
of the Ways and Means Committee thank
you for the opportunity to testify this
morning my name is Rebecca London I'm a
senior government Affairs manager at
DraftKings and I'm here to testify in
support of SB 104.
um in front of you you also have an
additional packet of information which
includes research from the American
gaming Association which represents both
brick and mortar and online casinos you
have numbers from states that have
legalized online casino products and you
have a dish some additional materials as
well including instances of consumers
that were illegally wagering and were
not protected by the consumer
protections that would be afforded
should you pass SB 104
um DraftKings is a digital Sports
entertainment and gaming company we're
headquartered in Boston and have an
office in Nashua we are live in over 17
countries including Casino product in
five states and Ontario and live with in
21 states with Sportsbook product
including here in New Hampshire and we
take a lot of pride in our partnership
with the New Hampshire lottery as an
authorized agent of online and Retail
sports betting
online gaming offers the state an
opportunity to capitalize on a new form
of Revenue providing citizens with new
forms of entertainment but without
having to raise taxes through November
of last year Connecticut a state roughly
twice the size of New Hampshire
generated more than 36 million dollars
in taxes with important priorities like
funding education legalization of online
gaming creates an opportunity to open
new doors
importantly we've seen that legalized
online gaming does not cannibalize other
forms of legal gaming you've heard
citations to New Jersey today what we've
it's the most mature and most robust
gaming state in the country and gross
Gaming revenue across all gaming sectors
including Lottery land-based casinos
sports betting and online gaming have
grown since 2018 with the numbers from
2022 expected to be the highest for all
gaming X sectors
what we see in those who are most likely
to participate in online gaming are not
doing so at the expense of existing
markets because it's typically users who
are doing so illegally and are of
different demographic than those of
current legal options
the American gaming Association
estimates there's as much as 338 billion
dollars wagered illegally annually
Nationwide including 46 billion dollars
in the Northeast alone
much like the successful Sports wagering
Market in the granite state legalizing
online gaming creates a market with a
known product where consumers are
guaranteed the protections they don't
receive in the illegal Market
should you choose to legalize New
Hampshire would be the first in Northern
New England to legalize online casino
products opening the market to
neighboring states much like you did
when you led on online sports betting
and Retail sports betting
to my point about taking consumer
protection seriously we
take the time to educate our customers
on the tools available to them like time
and deposit limits cool off periods and
resources to continue to use our
products for entertainment purposes we
fund responsible gaming initiatives and
research collaborate with stakeholders
and work to better understand our
players while training our employees to
understand signs of problem gaming New
Hampshire has the opportunity to lead in
the sector it provides additional
entertainment and revenue for your state
I'm more than happy to answer any
questions that you have this morning
representative Olney
thank you what do you mean by of a
different demographic sure so online
casino users typically are younger than
brick and mortar uh users and we saw one
example which is cited in your packet
that 80 percent of online users for one
specific Casino in Pennsylvania were
entirely unknown previously to that
casino so they were not in that casino's
representative Doucet
thank you madam chair thank you for
taking my question then the market in in
sports gaming has been mentioned a few
times the market for sports betting
online sports betting is
totally different from online gaming in
this form no
so to make it to make a comparison
between online sports betting and online
gaming table games
they're again apples and oranges thank
you for your question representative um
one way that you could see the
similarities is that some users who
prefer to go to get their ticket at a
retail facility for Sportsbook is
typically a different demographic than
those who place their Sports Wagers on
their phones or mobile devices much like
those who prefer to go to physical
locations to place a table game wager is
also a different demographic than those
that typically wager online and
therefore it opens up a new market of
users to
oh is there is that Lit for a reason yes
representative Jordan ulrey thank you
madam chair and thank you for taking my
question questions two primary questions
uh
the information you provided in here
appears to deal with illegal gaming and
yet
the issue that we've received the most
comment on is
um cannibalization to use Senator Lang's
terminology
do you have any statistical data on that
particular aspect representative thank
you for that question we do have
um there's a chart in your packet
um that looks like this
um it has different uh
um tables on it I suppose and that shows
the eye Gaming revenue versus the casino
revenue in four of the legal
jurisdictions here in the United States
follow up man chair
pull up
fine each one of these states has full
legalized gaming we don't
we have charitable gaming do you have
any information about charitable gaming
and its effect because that's a kind of
a different animal if you will
absolutely thank you representative
um and what I would say is as has been
noted this morning it is that New
Hampshire does have a unique way that
they deal with brick and mortar
locations I think
two things that would make us be able to
extrapolate the same information as
what's available in your packet is that
we're offering the same types of games
that are available at your brick and
mortar locations and that um again
they're they're different demographics
of users uh and they're so therefore we
would expect that you could
um and that gaming grows across all
sectors in legal online casino States
um not just in the brick and mortar
facilities
and Rich Parsons just um rip Granite
strategy is also at DraftKings to also
point out those other states also have
slots in their eye gaming products so
this is which make up roughly about 50
of
um gaming in those States okay the
technical question what please it's not
a follow-up different question
um you indicate that uh or the builds
indicates that it would be limited to
Geo limited geopens if you will to New
Hampshire however
I can look like I'm in France
with a VPN
how does that work absolutely I really
appreciate that question representative
we
um as I was talking about our consumer
protections one of the things that we do
is we work with sophisticated technology
providers to make sure that users cannot
spoof their location by using VPN or
other locations spoofing measures we
already do that with our product our
sports betting product here in New
Hampshire and it's the same technology
that's been tested and proven across
sports betting and online gaming across
the country where our technology
providers are able to detect those sorts
of technology and and prevent an
individual trying to wager that's not
located within the state of New
thank you very much
uh one more question representative almi
thank you
um
being that we are talking about a
different demographic which is the same
one that is supposedly being helped by
this bill
um
could do you have any data on the
percentage of people that are using the
the products that on
are putting limits on their own gaming
activity that's a really wonderful
question representative and I really
appreciate it uh this morning I don't
have those statistics off the top of my
head but I'd be more than happy to work
um with our internal team and also our
external problem gaming folks to get you
a picture of that thank you
thank you very much thank you very much
oh oh I'm sorry representative Doucet
you know what if you can guys it helps
me see you better if you could just turn
your light on that way I catch it I
apologize thank you thank you madam
chair and thank you for another question
here I'm curious if the platform you
have in place in four states right now
other five states and Ontario okay uh
other a and I know it can be addressed
eight uh limits to the table Stakes we
have a ten dollar limit in New Hampshire
are there any limits in those five
states
currently
none that are imposed in State Statute
but we do have user imposed
and and with that platform I even I
haven't actually used the DraftKings
platform but I'm sure you're aware
Foxwoods has put out a beta system for
online betting platform and in my
experience sitting at home in my
comfortable clothing
would it be possible on your platform to
deal myself 1200 hands of blackjack in
one hour on your platform three hands at
a time four hands at a time but with
that rapidity
that's a great question representative
so um the way the way my understanding
is because I also live in a jurisdiction
where our product is not legal is that
you are you're at a table and and you're
playing it as if you were you know at a
table in a location
quick follow-up so on your platform is
the ability to be at multiple tables at
the same time
available uh to be entirely honest with
you representative I'm not sure but I
can um I'll follow up with you you're
not sure okay
okay
thank you thank you very much okay I'm
just trying to go back and forth between
Pro versus con so we will now recognize
John
thank you
Eric queso from Meals on Wheels I
apologize please help us understand how
to say that
you did a great job
thank you madam chair thank you members
of the committee for the record my name
is John araquezzo and I am the president
and CEO of Meals on Wheels of
Hillsborough County and we are a
recipient of charitable gaming and and
very uh proud that the state supports it
this is an Innovative Bill and offers a
lot of solutions to a lot of problems
however I I don't think an adequate the
fiscal note adequately addresses the
income that the state is expecting
if if you could note it talks about in
Gross eye gaming revenues across four
states it doesn't really analyze gross
gaming revenues so I I've always viewed
this as a bubble as a balloon you know
you squeeze one end and
it's going to pop out here and get
smaller at the other end and and I'm
still of the belief that it's just
shifting monies around and
um and so to say that there's gross uh
you know because New Jersey is going to
get 138 million in Gross uh gaming
revenues we can expect the same it
really instead of looking at eye gaming
it needs to look at gross gaming across
the board
and so until that's until that's fully
vetted I'm very concerned about what
this could possibly do to Charities and
I'm going to keep it short and and my
testimony
would you be open to questions yes other
questions from the committee members
must be getting close to lunch thank you
chair recognizes Kathy prevention sorry
to keep you waiting
from the University system of New
Hampshire
good morning Madam chair and members of
the Ways and Means Committee
um thank you so much just a few brief
comments
um consistent with Chancellor Rubenstein
Stein's testimony we are not taking a
position on online gaming but the
university system fully supports all
efforts to encourage our New Hampshire
students to achieve their educational
goals here in New Hampshire and and this
is one way that um
we can do so by supporting community
college students but also supporting
efforts of the community college system
and the university system in transfer
Pathways House Bill 1530 I think was
passed last session and we are working
closely and collaboratively with the
community college system to ensure that
transfer pathways are seamless for
students from the community college
system to the university system and
Senate Bill 104 provides a
more opportunity and incentive to help
those students that wish to transfer to
a four-year degree we have some pretty
significant demographic challenges ahead
that are going to
truly impact the workforce the
demographic challenges across the
Northeast are making for very stiff
competition in higher education and
states are trying to steal students from
other states and Senate bill again 104
provides an opportunity to keep our New
Hampshire students here at a lower cost
than than a traditional four-year degree
our college going population is changing
lots of non-traditional students
students that start later students that
stop and start there's not a lot of
direct State support for scholarships
across the uh the state and especially
frankly for the non-traditional students
that attend the community college system
and Senate Bill 104 would would provide
such an opportunity I'm happy to take
any questions
thank you
seeing none thank you for your oh I
apologize did you have your hand up did
you representative Army
thank you I didn't want to ask this of
the previous people because you may have
more of an idea when uh online sports
betting started in this state
um have you seen any increase in
financial difficulties of the as they
put it demographic
uh that would be both benefited and
could be harmed by this not that I'm
aware of Representative Almy I haven't
studied that but not that I'm aware of
thank you
representative
thank you madam chair just to ask a
clarifying question thank you for taking
my question
um
would it be fair to say you're not
necessarily supportive of SB 104 but you
are supportive of any bill that would
help fund the university system
um yes not just not just the university
system again this is about all of our
New Hampshire students who seek to
achieve another level of educational
benefit so the answer is yes I would
thank you so much okay good okay good
um thank you thank you so
going back and forth we have Bill Dunlap
from New Hampshire Historical Society
sir could you do me a favor and just
turn on the button on the right you'll
see a red thing that comes on no on the
bottom
yes there you go thank you sorry uh this
New Hampshire Historical Society is
celebrating his 200th anniversary this
year so we've been around a long time we
like many charitable organizations the
state uh really depend on the funding we
get from the charitable gaming program
uh New Hampshire has a very lean and
efficient state government and I think
non-profits
play arguably a greater role in this
state than maybe any other in the
country we're one example
um uh a few years ago we became aware of
a real problem in elementary education
in the area of History social studies
and Civics the curriculum was out of
date and it was not being taught as much
as it had been in previous years and we
stepped in and developed a curriculum we
raised 1.2 million dollars in private
donations and used our own resources as
well to develop a new curriculum for
that were being were providing free of
charge to every school in the state as
well as homeschoolers it's very
successful called Moose on the loose we
would not be able to do this without uh
the substantial support we get from a
lot of our stakeholders one of the key
ones is charitable gaming our annual
fund is about three hundred thousand
dollars a year and that's part important
part an important part of our Revenue
about a quarter of that total comes from
the charitable gaming funding
so we rely on it and I'd just like to
close by saying that I have no
statistical
data to talk about so-called
cannibalization or diversion of funding
from currents current sources but it
just seems to me as a practical matter
sort of common sense if you look at
e-commerce in the world of business the
availability of of buying products
online certainly has an impact on bricks
and mortar and I I can't believe it
would not be the same case here thank
you
okay the chair recognizes Randy Pierce
and I don't know what this is exactly
but for future sight but I'm missing a
word future insight there it is okay
all right
so thank you very much Madam chair I am
randy Pierce from future Insight who
many of you may know by our 110 year
history as the New Hampshire Association
for the Blind and you know we have a
difficult task just like you right we
serve the whole state from
every age birth to Earth as we say and
we serve every aspect low vision to no
vision and that's a big charge there's
28 000 people in our state that that
affects and I share those numbers
because I want to share a couple of
numbers right ways and means you're
focused on numbers and you should be
the the bill is put forth to solve a
problem and provide funding where
there's a need and I get that but I want
to talk about where our need is right in
the last five years Public Funding has
dropped 62 percent that's a result of
how the world reacts in the last two
years we introduced historic horse
racing which has been a benefit in fact
Senator Lang talked about how they
looked at it holistically how can they
help benefit the Charities even as they
may take away a little from the
Charities and the reality is it cut our
our benefit almost in half in the last
year from that and I understand the
reasons and maybe that will grow and
have room to grow because candidly
charitable gaming has grown slightly
every year to help us do what we do but
the biggest challenge we're faced is so
it did get halved if this bill passes
what amount will it reduce it's
speculative but you know even in the
best case example I heard 20 were not
new demographics you're going to take
away 20 of our funding again that'd be
significant and
what we need to do is find solutions for
all the problems that's what we as
Charities are trying to do to fill in
the gap
and in doing that it helps when we can
have a budget and some predictability
and what does the amount we lost last
year represent it represents one VRT
Vision Rehabilitation therapist now most
Rehabilitation if you have a physical
disability you need that help you get
that support it's even medically paid
for
but sensory Rehabilitation doesn't apply
if you're blind if you're a senior who's
losing sight so significantly that you
can't navigate your home we have to go
into your home whether you live in
Colebrook where I grew up whether you
live in Nashua where I lived all my life
we've got to travel to you
and one VRT salary means two visits a
day because three hours and whatever
geographic location we're going to you'd
multiply that times five days times 52
weeks that's how many people now aren't
going to get just a three hour visit
and boy when you lose your sight three
hour visit is probably not enough to
help you gauge and adjust all the things
you need now we're going to do that
either way but we're going to have to
reduce the number if you reduce our
number and that's why I'm here to plea
for you to really consider if you don't
have enough confidence that there is no
impact and you're not prepared to
understand the real person impact that
that means
then maybe this is the time to say no to
that bill to make sure you'd give that
security and to find what other avenues
may exist because I don't think this is
a new stream I think it may have some
new stream potential but it's going to
have a lot of old stream detriment and
that's what I'd like to avoid and the
reason I know that is because right 33
years ago when I went blind if I didn't
get that basic training if I didn't get
that support I wouldn't be a
contributing member of society as I am
today as I lead the organization
and I wonder how many of the people that
we serve today can't get that level of
service already because of the
reductions and how many more will
struggle to meet each year so thank you
for consideration I'll happily take any
questions
swirl however my guy Doug will not
answer any
thank you so much for your testimony
representative Platt yes thank you in
full disclosure both Randy Pierce and I
are lions and he came from it was in the
Hudson line for the longest time and you
associate with Concord now so I'm still
a Hudson lion member because I pay
attention to my roots but I'm also an
associate member at the Concord Lions
thank you I just want to put that forth
and that's why I knew him he runs future
insight and I treasure Lion's sight and
hearing Foundation
um but I did not understand with your
testimony how your benefit did get cut
in half you said was that Federal yeah
no no no that's so that was a decision
with historic horse racing we know
that's going to raise the revenues but
we also split it now so Charities have
to share that time and while they didn't
quite cut it in half it was very close
and I support that I mean we won't help
all the Charities we're all doing good
things out here but the more you splice
it the more you reduce it the more that
affects our bottom line budget how we
and for the record my family has
received many of your great services and
we really appreciate it thank you for
what you do other questions
okay sing none thank you very much thank
represent uh no uh Rick Newman from the
New Hampshire charitable gaming
operators
thank you madam chair my name is Rick
Newman I'm representing the New
Hampshire charitable gaming operators
Association we appear in opposition to
Senate bill 104. and I'm not going to
take a lot of your time I put down two
minutes I'm going to try to hold uh to
that uh I a couple of points I'd like to
make first uh representative Lloyd I
believe asked a question
how much does charity gaming generate uh
currently so we mailed out a brochure to
the whole house and when we put that
together last November the amount was
about 20 million dollars uh the previous
year right now if you look at the
numbers from Lottery it looks to me like
we're probably on track to be somewhere
around 25 perhaps even 28 million uh in
the next year
as as those numbers have gone up so and
that that is a benefit that is spread
out among
um
well at least about a thousand Charities
to share that money we are very
concerned about uh online gaming uh
particularly the way this bill presents
it with no limits on Wagers and that
sort of thing and and what it will what
impact it will have we've we have seen
the impact when for instance Encore in
Massachusetts when during covet when
they're they tighten their hours when
they got rid of Poker we saw our numbers
go up
when they brought poker back for
instance we saw our numbers go down
there's a I mean it's just it's a real
correlation so uh I've seen the ads from
DraftKings that are I think effective
advertising where they say you know when
it's bad weather stay on your couch and
bet from home
and uh you know if you encourage people
to do that of course you're going to
take them away from brick and mortar
from the charity casinos couple of
Statistics I want to give you
um
charity gaming employs about 1500 people
in the state now believe it or not think
about that I mean we have you know 1500
people working and I'll tell you that
about three years ago
a dealer was making
in the neighborhood of eight to ten
dollars an hour plus tips and the tips
are very good so dealers were very happy
you can't get dealers for eight to ten
dollars anymore so you're paying
20 22 some even more to get uh workers
just like every other business has seen
a post-covered world wages wages have
gone up and that has had which means
obviously the employees are making more
money but
online gaming produces zero jobs I mean
there will be there's no job creation
and this and in fact we think it will
cost jobs because it will see a
reduction in uh revenue for the
Charities so I I think it's important to
consider the job implication the number
of Charities that are benefited and the
amount of money that we generally that
we generate to Charities
um finally I don't have it with me but I
have seen a study by Deutsche Bank which
I will send to the committee after this
hearing uh where New Jersey Pennsylvania
Michigan they saw a 12 percent drop in
brick and mortar casino revenue when
online gaming went
uh into effect uh so I I will share that
with you and I'll end my testimony there
thank you very much uh are you open to
questions I am
going around the room
seeing none thank you very much
that's all I have for people who want to
testify the uh Charlie McIntyre is here
if we had technical questions for him
wow we ended before lunch what that's a
miracle right there uh is there anyone
else here who would like to testify on
Senate Bill 104. seeing none we will
close the public healing and we will be
in recess until
one o'clock
thank you
foreign
we will now open the public hearing on
Senate Bill 51. the chair recognizes
Senator Tim Lang who will introduce the
bill welcome back
thank you members of the committee
thanks for taking my testimony again
you'll hear me at least twice more today
uh next two bills are also mine so
um uh Senate bill 51.
um there was a conversation that
occurred uh but so the first thing this
thing does it establish a study
committee to look at what's going on in
charitable gaming and and how revenues
are being split and and those kind of
things uh and it and it extends the
moratorium out an additional two years
basically until 2026.
um so I'll talk a little bit about why
this bill came forward so originally
when historic horse racing was passed we
put a three-year moratorium on there and
the idea was to see what is this going
to do to our revenues how is it going to
impact the Charities how's it going to
impact gaming operators how it's going
to impact the state
um the problem was that through
negotiations between the state the
channel gaming operators and
representatives the rules for this
particular form of gaming HHR took 18
months after passage before they were
adopted so half of the moratorium had
gone by we don't before a single license
was even issued so the goal of this bill
is to extend the more to warm out a
little further form a study committee
and take a look at what the impact of
historic horse racing along with other
charitable gaming functions
um
have on our Charities so I don't know if
you know but when you talk about
historic horse racing the revenue splits
that occur for table games versus
historic horse racing are different
and so we don't know what the impact of
this is so before we unleash this on
anybody you know however many more
operators we kind of want to take a look
at what that Revenue split is doing to
the Charities how that's working whether
it's beneficial to the Charities or
harmful to the Charities what's going on
but we need data to do that which means
there's only currently I think seven
operating HHR locations out of the I
think there's 16 if Charlie's here you
can correct me but I think 15. 16
licenses that have been issue that are
eligible for HHR only seven have chosen
to implement and even of those seven I
think two of them came on in the last
couple months and so the point is to
extend out the moratorium collect the
data on what's going on in these General
gaming locations and how it impacts our
Charities here in New Hampshire
I'm happy to take any questions
seeing none sweet thank you okay and uh
The Honorable representative Pat abrami
is here
welcome back
thank you madam chair and uh
hello committee
so uh Madam chairman here to support the
bill uh first off
understand there were originally two two
Senate bills there was Senator
Dalessandro's Bill 90 Senate Bill 90 and
then uh
representative Lang's Senate Bill 51 uh
Senator Senator donisandro's Bill was a
pure commission Bill and then Senator
langsville was a commission bill but
also included this uh continued
moratorium on uh game operators from
having uh uh historic racing
so and then representative Ames had
House Bill 220 which I saw was uh which
did a lot of the same things but as a
committee a joint committee with the
Senate and not a commission
uh understand the commission is going to
include people from the AG's office from
the lottery from actually some Charities
some of the uh the game operators as
well to make it a broader a group of
people
uh
so the but the Senate merged the two
bills and they they itl uh Senator
Dalessandro's bill
now before he filed the bill Senator
Alessandro called me
because I've been very involved in this
total charitable gaming thing and he
says Pat how'd you like to be on the
commission
and I said sure as a matter of fact I'd
like you to chair it
but that's that's up to the commission
once it's formed as to who's going to
chair it uh so uh that's why they they
put in the bill a a
citizen appointed by the governor
so
um
the uh
again last term we had a joint committee
uh studying this as well
uh uh and it was representative Ames was
on it senator of Representative Doucet
was on it I was on it and we when we did
a pretty good a pretty good job I
thought of of looking at we toured we
toured five of these locations uh two in
Nashua one in Keene one in Manchester
and one in Seabrook
and we
you know we asked a lot of questions we
saw for our very eyes that they have the
cameras everywhere on the players on the
dealers we saw that there were cameras
in that cage where the money's counted
uh and from our tertiary review it
appeared that a lot of the rules and
regulations that you would find in a
true Casino are in place
but now that charitable gaming is
growing even more uh I think it's time
to
even look even further I know Senator
Senator I promoted to representative
Ames years ago when we were still
looking at uh regular regular large size
casinos did a lot of work in developing
rules regulations and I'm sure in your
executive in your executive when your
second issue probably
add to what I'm about to say but uh that
was very helpful it was now whether or
not all of those kind of things are in
how we're looking at our current
charitable gaming is is another story
so so with with that said the other
there's another provision in here
um
that is asking for 250 thousand dollars
now I don't want I don't want this bill
to die because Finance doesn't want to
see 250 000 spent on this I think we can
do it without the 250 000 I think that
250 000 will allow us to hire
uh outside experts to come in and maybe
do reviews of our charitable locations I
I don't know but I'm not quite sure how
we're going to spend that money uh but
that that is in the bill
uh just uh just this morning I printed
where we are uh yeah you know this month
and by the way and the bill says that
that money will come out of this year's
Surplus
okay but to be spent next year
okay and the other thing is that this
bill is is a goes a year and a half it
doesn't it isn't a commission that ends
next November it ends in November 24. uh
which is good because you know uh I
think it will need that time
so
um
but we're as of this morning I've the
report that you'll get where it was 66.9
ahead of Target just in this month alone
uh and that brings us
to have it here somewhere
that brings us to I don't know nearly
400 uh
I got it right here that that thing is a
390 right now you had a date uh but
we'll be well above 400 000 above Target
now whether or not Finance has already
spent that money is another question I'm
assuming Senate has this 250 in their
radar I'm not sure if we do or not on
our side here on the house side
um very good and then the only other
thing I want to say about extending that
date you know last thought
so
um let me lose my notes Here
as Senator as representative Senator
Lang said
uh the game operator moratorium
doesn't mean okay so we went back to May
1st you had to be
a a game operator for charitable gaming
employer
as of May 1st 2020 to be eligible to be
to take on uh historic racing and that
moratorium went to July 1st of 2024.
this bill changes that to July 1st of
2026 another two years
it doesn't mean that if you or I wanted
to get a license to be a game operator
employer it doesn't stop you from doing
that you can still become a game
operator employer if you pass all the
rules the regular background checks and
everything else but you just can't have
historic racing
okay this is a moratorium on new
facilities
that became charitable gaming locations
after May 1st of 2020. so I just want to
make sure that's clear so it doesn't
prevent anybody from becoming a
but you can't just have Charo you cannot
have historic racing for additional two
years going all the way out to 2026 so
that's my testimony
I'll take questions thank you oh we'll
start over here representative Phillips
thank you madam chair
um could could you just give me your
opinion on the scope of what the
committee is looking at it looks it
looks pretty narrow to me it doesn't
seem to look at any yes that sometimes
that happens in these commissions every
commission I've I've chaired probably
five commissions over the years
once we get rolling we always broaden
those the scope as we once we once we
start digging and finding issues we
broaden the scope
um I mean I think there are other things
uh that we'll probably be looking at
other than that
again I didn't I didn't write the scope
I I just you know
pull up yep so I'm you know I'm fairly
new but I've seen other bills that say
things like when you have a study
committee or Commission in in the
usually the last sentences and other
relevant things
some something along that line so it
because this doesn't have a statement
like that dude
do you think that would be a good idea
should should well if you feel again
it's never stopped me in the past that
it's not believe me there's there's no
police if you will that view what uh
what a commission does be honest with
you I've shared a lot of them
and uh we we take us with a facts lead
and then if we we turn into the stone
over and we see something that we need
to explore we explore it
other hands on this side representative
Ames
thank you and it's good to see you yeah
good seeing you
um
and we work together on this issue right
I I had two things one is um
as you pointed out there's another bill
that I filed that calls for our
legislative study
and that was actually a pickup from the
work that you and I did on the
legislative Joint Committee that we both
participated on along with with uh
representative
Doucette do set sorry I know it but it
didn't come up Fred scrolling
that wasn't there
um
and uh
I hope you wouldn't be surprised that AI
filed it because all of a sudden you
weren't returning
and I felt I knew this would be
something you would want
but b or second
um would you be surprised that I agree
way to go forward is with this bill
rather than with my my bill which is now
retained by this committee so it can't
be acted on until
really until next year and we this bill
allows us to get going immediately yes
it gives us almost two years to work but
but a year and a half ish and uh
definitely it'll be broader than we'll
have the right people at the table uh
talking through these issues uh it's
it's looking like they're going to allow
us some money to actually bring in other
experts from afar
to help us out so that's certainly a
different thing than a joint committee
uh would be able to do
and then on the money question and
the commission question
um
the one of the key differences between
my bill and this bill is on those two
points there's no money in my bill and
there's a narrower narrower group of
people because it's restricted to house
members and Senate members
um
uh
I can say that it has been my experience
much less than yours
as a member of a commission which I led
on the casinos yes you did
um
that having an appropriation having
money to get experts in made a huge
difference and would you agree that one
of the difficulties with you and I faced
on that legislative joint committee was
that we didn't have that kind of support
you know we as a constant scramble in
the work we do here in the legislature
to find enough time for anything to
focus on anything and without help it
makes it that much more difficult so
um
maybe you could flesh out a little bit
how you would see the money being
helpful to this commission and making a
difference making it able to make a
greater difference than it would
otherwise be again it's the it's the
ability to uh
you know the travel issue for experts uh
We've pretty much conquered that by
using Zoom I've done commissions now to
review Skype review Zoom uh you know to
bring in people from other states and
I've I've kind of uh I think I was the
first one of the first legislators to uh
to get permission to do that on a
commission to you know when I was doing
the marijuana commission I couldn't I
couldn't bring in people from California
or Colorado we just didn't have the
budget to fly people in and they're not
going to come on their own
uh Maine and Massachusetts came to us
because they're fairly local but
sometimes there were experts uh that
we'd all love to hear from on issues
that uh we're not able to bring in but
with with zoom these days as long as
you're allowed to use the zoom uh it it
works okay uh but I think the other
thing we can do is you know technically
my understanding is that Lottery has
inspectors okay so they do inspect these
facilities periodically as to their
practices and all of that the one
question I have is I mean I I'm sure
they have outside Auditors auditing
their books
because one question I've always had is
uh is is I have no reason to believe
this okay but I'm saying as you just
saying well why do we have audits well
you're you're protecting the
shareholders
but in a way the the the the the
uh shareholders in part now are the
charities
you know if we write them if we write a
charity a check for sixty five thousand
dollars
and they get and but they really do 70
000 are they really going to complain no
we have to make sure
that that
the books are good you know and I and
that's one of the things I do want to
take up in the commission uh that that
issue uh that we can all feel
comfortable again there's no reason I
have no reason to believe
that there's a problem I'm just saying
but doesn't mean you shouldn't check
so uh that's one thing I mean maybe we
have we bring in another uh possible
thing is to bring in a uh uh some kind
of an accountant that could just do some
random checks on on some of the books uh
just to see so uh so yeah I think we'll
find use of the money uh and we'll you
know it'll be up to the commission we'll
be discussing that as to how how best is
to spend that money
um
okay so one of the things I want to
mention I almost forgot
was I guess there's been a rule change
since for this year where a certain
percentage of commission members have to
be legislators
so this is forced to get to get the
number of of
uh I don't know if it's just a center
rule because I know the Senate was two
two things that I've testified on so far
I had a higher number of of uh of reps
than normal
this one calls for five reps
and two senators
uh which is great if you know usually
members like to participate in these
things uh but sometimes it's hard you
know we always have trouble getting two
senators period let alone let alone one
uh so uh I just pointed out that there's
some kind of a new rule and I don't know
if that rule is also in the house or not
someone know that answer I I don't know
but there's a senate rule because they
made a big deal about it
over in the Senate when this bill was
being heard in the Senate it was less
there was four reps someone did the math
said nope we need to have five reps so
just be aware we have to find and it
probably come from ways of means I don't
know what other committee they would
come from
uh it's asking for for five reps so
um that's a change
usually we do three
three and two and then we we get one
from the Senate we're happy
so
other questions from the committee
representative Elber
thank you madam chair and I'm not sure
this is Jermaine to now and maybe a
conversation to have at another time but
I am curious about
um commission membership this came up
several months ago when we were talking
about Water's Edge business taxes uh
where there was a commission that didn't
have members and so it it's work hadn't
gotten even started and I'm just
wondering if at some point somebody can
enlighten me and maybe others about what
happens with commissions that aren't
if this is the same commission that I
was sharing
uh that it was an odd it was an oddly
written commission that crossed
legislative
uh sessions if you will
it went across after an elect you know
it's it's one thing to have a two-year
commission when you have it when you
form it the first year of the two years
because the house members are all the
house members
Senator spellsbury are we talking about
the same one Let's help me out is this
the same one uh yes just to clarify same
commission and I believe representative
elberger's point is that there are some
non-legislative positions that never
were filled oh yes right some vacancies
right I got it but but again that was an
odd one at a crossed lines so I
basically handed off to Baton to
representative spellsbury who was an
active member on that that commission to
be
I anointed him to chair at least to call
the next meeting
and then but when I talked to the folks
up on the fourth floor they said it was
odd that this this commission actually
went across congrats legislative
uh years uh that so
uh
but yes we had trouble
filling all the seats I was in the
process of I had uh reached out to a few
others
and then when I didn't get reelected I
kind of stopped doing that uh yes so yes
sometimes we do have trouble uh getting
them it's up to the uh who who appoints
those it's the clerk's office
excuse me it's the uh
yeah it's the clerk's office who has to
call
the various like uh the uh
the association of accountants or
whatever it might be they'll call and
say hey we have this commission can you
help us out can you find someone to to
fill that position that's what happens
and I kept on going back to the because
I held off starting the meeting because
I I eventually I got a few more people
this was the hardest one ever because it
was a very very technical
kind of a topic
and it was hard to fill all those seats
with the right the right people that
were knowledgeable
uh so and I don't know where it stands
today but uh you know that's basically
the back story on that but it's declared
it's the clerk's office when it comes to
house members
it's the it's the speakers the speaker's
office gets the list
speakers people will will appoint and
usually the chair they'll usually call
the chair and ask for of the committee
and say hey who do you suggest
uh for the committee so
thank you very much wait are we good oh
representative or sorry thank you madam
chair thanks for taking my questions so
just a couple things on the first page
on line 19 it talks about whether
charging rent to Charities is necessary
with historic horse racing we've heard
in previous testimony I guess some of
the Halls charged by the head five
dollars or you know I guess that's a
rent so what is the question with
historic horse racing I'm not sure
well with historic horse racing
these facilities are getting a lot more
Revenue
and where basically the question is do
we really need to charge the Charities
rent
I always had a problem with with
personally even before historic racing
charging the Charities rent now that the
philosophy behind the rent
is that
uh you know it used to be in the old
days
let me
charitable gaming used to be
you know the the gambling company would
come with the roulette wheel and go to
the basement of the church and you would
have a charitable function somewhere
along the line before my time someone
had the bright idea saying well why
don't we have fixed locations
and that's what this is about so now
there's fixed locations now there's 16
of them
um and uh
so
in those days in the beginning the
Charities actually had to do something
they actually had to come and actually
participate and touch the money
which was not a good idea but over time
it's morphed now into all they have to
do is sign a piece of paper somewhere
along the line and pick up the check
uh so the so the operator said well wait
a minute we're doing all the work for
you that we used to do
so we're going to charge you rent
somewhere along the line that happened
and now the question on the table is
is that really necessary given that
we've we've passed historic horse racing
which is is increasing everybody's
Revenue Charities and the locations is
it really fair to continue to charge the
Charities event so that's why that
that's my understanding of why that
one's on the same list thank you and
follow up
uh online same page line 23 it says uh
additional licenses for historical horse
racing machines would increase or reduce
revenues to Charities did you have a
chance to look into that enough to
determine if there was an impact on
other charities
you know so we're on line 20 what 20
it's line 24 23 and 4.
additional license for HHR machines
would increase or reduce revenues to
charity
I didn't know if you'd gotten into
enough to have any feel for whether or
not there were any impacts one way or
another
well I've been in contact with a lot of
charitable gaming locations
and they're all picking up new Charities
because what we did
first off is in the bill the historic
cost facing bill
we our goal was to double the number
charity because one of the big
complaints we heard from charities
is that we can never get a date all the
dates are are taken there's like about
500 Charities that were taking part in
in charitable gaming
so we said we're gonna if we're gonna do
historic racing we're going to help out
we want to help out other charities
and we basically so every every date has
two Charities now that if you have
historic racing machines you have two
day two Charities involved and the money
split so uh
my understanding is and I've been to the
brook uh for an event I've been to uh
Manchester for another event
talking to the owners there and they've
all said that yeah they're having no
problem finding additional charities
and you know the goal is we can get up
to around a thousand Charities if we
double okay so I don't know if that was
your question but yes no that's good and
just keep me in mind if you need an
auditor as an auditor for a number of
years and I figure you're 250 000 just
might cover my fees believe me it's not
mine I didn't write the bill I probably
wouldn't have written for 250 in it
because it's my fiscal conservative side
of tech I really want to spend 250 of
them so but not the more I think about
it it's probably not a bad idea so
thank you very much oh sorry
representative Lloyd hopefully a very
quick question
um so I'm seeing in here that there
would be two representatives of
charitable gaming Charities
um and I'm just kind of curious you may
not be the person to ask this question
of but who how are those Charities
chosen I mean given my non-profit work I
worked for non-profits that are 10
people I've worked with non-profits that
are 8 000 people so like yeah
um there would be very different right I
mean that's a that's a good that's a
good question I'm not sure how we're
gonna
uh you know on the on the owner's side
we have the same question
although there's there's some
consolidation going on in that
some of the some of the owners are now
buying out some of the other locations
okay so but there's an association
that you know but look the language is
the language uh we'd have to figure out
and I I would imagine that the uh we
should give some advice to the
uh clerk's office when they're reaching
out
to what charities maybe we'll Define the
bigger chair maybe one big charity one
small charity or something like that but
that's a good find that's a good that's
a good question again I I you know I saw
the bill the first time when it was in
the Senate but
um
representative
thank you that just brought up a
question for me on have we got something
in the law that says that the owner has
to be from New Hampshire because my uh
Paul which is going to be a lot bigger
soon is
um has been bought out by a group in
one has to be a resident of New
Hampshire yes right is there
is there sure that it's the New
Hampshire people that end up yeah I I
guess
we do have um
again
the one that we yield to uh is the
commission is going to have somebody
from the AG's office Attorney General
um and those are the kind of questions
that I think we need to focus on
what happened that that that's all being
done right
and the one big issue for me was
uh the one thing we did find uh
representative Ames uh and uh to set was
um
how did the Charities get picked
you know is there favoritism I mean is
it how do you get how who who gets first
priority but believe me when when organs
when Charities learn about charitable
gaming and as many of them know about
this
they're all salivate because be honest
with you the bigger places now
they're walking away with checks for a
hundred thousand
so we're talking big money too so uh so
the question is
and then in our interviews that was one
of the questions that we've always asked
was how do you how do you pick how do
you prioritize with Charities and they
all kind of had different methodologies
for that
I know when we were at the brook uh we
met with the owner
and he had a good answer he goes well we
do what we're doing is that after every
year
uh they they're going to ask how did the
charity spend the money
they want to know how specifically each
charity spent the money
uh and that would guide them as to
whether they
are you know there are a lot of
safeguards in there you have to wait a
year uh you can't be a charity that just
all of a sudden opened up shop and asked
to open a historic charitable gaming
location you have to you have to wait a
year
okay excuse me back back up that you you
can't just be in the Charity saying I
want to I want to be uh considered
uh used me too that got changed to one
but it's it's a year waiting period we
just don't want Charities popping up
everywhere saying hey we're a charity
with no track record
so you see the more we talk about this
issue there's a lot of subtleties that I
know are going to come up in this
commission to make sure that it's as
tight as can be and that's that's what
thank you very much oh one more
representative fellows
thank you madam chair
um I had a bill that recently passed the
house in the Senate it was a study
committee
but it had representative it had people
on the committee
um
let me start again
one of the things I know about study
commissions versus committees is that it
can take a long time to get it set up
because you have to select people from
outside the legislature and when I
mentioned that to OLS when I was
drafting a bill for a study committee
and I told him that I wanted it to be a
committee but I thought I had to make it
a commission because of that issue what
they did is they put together a
committee and voting members were just
housing House and Senate representative
is there a question here yes relevant
then within that um
bill it's said that certain agencies
would provide expertise to the um to the
committee including sometimes
identifying specific
um people you know positions within the
government so I'm concerned about what
kind of decision you're going to get
from this commission when you have
voting members that are Facility Owners
in charity in representing Charities and
that just to get I know it's putting you
on the spot but to get your reaction to
somehow restructuring this to be a
committee with just
senators and representatives voting but
identifying people that should assist
them you know representatives of
Charities or something along that line
there's different kind of commissions
too I mean so the fact that we have them
at the table
um
gives them the feeling that
they are participating that they are at
the table
uh
let me give you I I've chaired a couple
of commissions on um
on uh the assessing of utility
properties as some of the federal
members know I talk about telephone Paul
electric poles all the time
but I needed everybody in the room
because I needed the I needed the
municipalities in the room I needed the
uh
um
uh the the
utility companies in the room and I
needed the assess assessing
organizations in the room
because my goal was to fix a problem
that that commission was fixing a
problem and the goal was to get them all
in the room and bang their heads
together I started that meeting by
saying do all does anybody in the room
think there's no problem
and everybody said no that's a problem
so good we're going to fix the problem
so that's one kind of commission
um
I mean there there are others but I
think it's important uh that we have now
in the marijuana commission what
happened at the end
is that some of the agencies that we had
but we had Health and Human Services we
had State Police we had others on the
commission there was 17 members
all are very helpful very people
perspective we had all these
perspectives
but what happened at the end
they had trouble signing off on the
report
because
they didn't want
they didn't want their agencies to be
saying that they support or not support
so we had a disclaimer in the report
they said this this is no way represents
the uh feelings of Health and Human
Services or something that affect okay
that's what we that's why we did that
but it was it was very helpful to have
them at the table though so
I mean
so I I
would keep it as a commission so we
could get I don't think
first off again I think just having them
at the table is important to get their
perspective have them be able to speak
up at any time
how they feel about whatever the issue
we're talking about and then we'll just
okay
thank you are we ready to move on thank
you so much for taking so many questions
sorry
sure
on I've looked them up are you aware
that this is also an early Bill oh gosh
oh oh yes yes I did get the update yeah
there's three early bills this is one of
them yes thank you thank you for that
reminder this bill's going to finance
yes this is
where I'm more nervous now
okay great thank you so much thank you
okay the chair will recognize Alyssa not
sure how to pronounce your last name but
margolia from New Hampshire Center for
non-profits and if I didn't say so
earlier I am impacted this by this bill
uh because I'm involved in this industry
good afternoon Madam chair thank you
members of the committee for the record
my name is Alyssa margolin I'm a public
policy consultant with the New Hampshire
Center for non-profits we're a Statewide
organization that strengthens and gives
voice to New Hampshire's nonprofit
sector I don't have the opportunity to
be in front of this committee often so
I've shared with you New Hampshire
Center for nonprofits policy framework
to give you a sense of our advocacy and
the issues that we focus on
most recently issues related to
charitable gaming and the important
Revenue that impacts our members has
come to the attention of our policy
committee
the members of New Hampshire Center for
nonprofits really range in size as was
noted before we have very small
community
volunteer staffed public gardening
organizations all the way to ex very
very large educational and Healthcare
organizations
um of our members some not all
participate in charitable gaming and are
interested in issues that are uh noted
in this proposal including the selection
process issues around rental fees and so
we'd like to ask your committee to
consider adding the New Hampshire Center
for non-profits to this proposed study
commission the New Hampshire Center for
nonprofits has partnered on commissions
has also partnered with the governor's
office for emergency relief and recovery
on issues related to the pandemic we are
one of the partner organizations that
helped administer
resources related to the pandemic we
also provided some survey work some
pulse survey work the center puts out a
number of reports
including annual wage and benefit
reports and I think we see this
Statewide scope and really understand
the needs of the nonprofit sector as you
know in New Hampshire the nonprofit
sector is integral to our state's
well-being in many communities uh the uh
particularly social services play a role
that perhaps in other states would be
held by government so we're really
integral into
um
uh delivering services and the
well-being of our community and we'd
really like to be part of this
commission thank you for your
consideration and I'm happy to take any
questions
okay the chair will recognize Rick
Newman from New Hampshire charitable
thank you madam chair Rick Newman New
Hampshire charitable gaming operators
Association
um
we support this bill we support of the
continuation of studying charity gaming
through the commission and we support
the a two-year extension of the
moratorium I just quickly will want to
make a point that Senator Lang said when
the bill was originally passed to allow
historic racing it was anticipated that
the eligible rooms would have
three years where they would have the
opportunity to ramp up and get
established and as we know currently
seven of the 15 eligible locations still
do not have historic Racing for various
reasons
um but so we think that it's appropriate
to extend this moratorium out uh two
years and give those rooms that
opportunity
um
and that completes my testimony
I actually have a technical question so
does this get rid of another study
commission that was in effect I believe
it repeals the study commission that's
being established
um if you look at the dates right isn't
it
I think it's creating the study
commission and then two years it repeals
it ah okay gotcha just just seeing what
was going on with that just trying to
understand okay any questions for Mr
Newman
thank you very much okay I do not have
any more pink cards for Senate Bill 51
and it's getting late so we're going to
close the public hearing on Senate Bill
51. thank you
we will open the public hearing on
Senate Bill 120 relative to charitable
gaming license application wages stakes
and bonds
and for the record I am involved in this
industry
uh with chair will recognize Senator Tim
Lang
thank you madam chair and I won't give
my introduction again I'll just go right
into the bill so Senate Bill 120 uh is
similar to a bill you've already heard
which is house bill
um 607.
um the short version of what this bill
does it extends licenses from an annual
process to a three-year process without
changing a licensing fee
it also but it requires an annual
reporting of change so if there is a
change if there's no change there's no
need to report but if there is a change
he gain the gaming operators would have
to file a an amended or the amended
information with Lottery
um it just takes away the licensing
requirement that that becomes an annual
event and make it a three-year licensing
event the other thing this bill does is
increase the Wagers again similar to the
house bill 607 except that my Stakes are
a little higher you guys passed 25 for a
wager this bill is fifty dollars per
wager so I want to talk a little bit
about that about why that number went up
so dramatically and why I support that
idea of that number so you heard from
the Charities one of the first things is
that Charities are seeing a reduction in
giving
um in our in our state this is a way of
again
um
of of allowing more money to flow into
charitable gaming that results in more
money going to Charities by raising it
up to fifty dollars the other aspect you
heard uh earlier from uh I think was
Rick Newman talking about how much he
pays dealers right the ability for an
operator to be able to raise wages is
directly related to the amount of money
they take in they don't take the money
in they can't raise the wages for their
employees and so this bill will allow
The Operators on the operator side to
make more Revenue to be able to increase
salaries for the workforce that is
currently existing you heard earlier
there are 1500 employees in a charitable
gaming industry this will allow the
charitable gaming operators more Revenue
to be able to raise the wages for the
salary for those workers
um
the other reason why this this bill was
put in was we now have some competition
both to the to the west of uh to the
east of us and to the south of us that
we have over in Maine the New Oxford
Casino which is on the main border and
we have in Massachusetts in Boston The
Encore casino and and over in the
western edge of the state in Springfield
we got MGM so understand that our gaming
operators are competing for game for
gamblers for people who want to want to
come in and play and if uh on a Friday
and Saturday night if a game if a person
interested in in participating is
offered the choice of going to Boston
for where they have a higher bet limit
as compared to New Hampshire and they're
a serious poker player they're going to
go to where the money is and go down to
Boston so the goal of raising these
another goal of this is to retain the
money that's coming to New Hampshire in
New Hampshire and also understand again
we also attend attract Massachusetts
residents to also come up because our
gaming our gaming operations are on par
with Massachusetts gaming operations and
we're not at we're not working at a
deficit right off the bat
this bill does not contain and 607 is
where your moratorium bill was you had a
moratorium on historic horse racing I
chose to break that out and put it into
its own separate bill which we just
heard
um rather than include it as part of
this conversation
I'm happy to take questions again but I
think as I spoke to earlier all of these
bills were looked at holistically in
providing the best opportunity for
charitable gaming to stay competitive in
our state to be able to keep the the
gaming operators in business and working
and be able to work with their employees
and their Charities as well
wow seeing none oh you're awesome
representative Pillsbury
with apologies for uh keeping you
um
I raised this question on 607 when we
got to exec and had not been present
during the hearing so I'll raise it
again with you in this bill
both bills delete
a substantial language
is a section that relates to penalties
and it's divided into a part a
and a Part B
uh curiously there is a part C and uh HP
607 had all three of them
in each case the current law
lists specific
instances that would constitute under a
a minor violation under B A moderate
violation and under C
a major violation
and
each of those also includes language
that says may include but is not limited
to so that the Lottery Commission
would find in these specific instances a
violation according to the tier of
severity
and could find others that aren't listed
that would be comparable
at the least this is indicative it
doesn't limit
the ability of the commission to find
other instances that are of commensurate
harm
so my that sounds like a very good
convention
why are we deleting all that language
excuse me and what is it that we end up
with if we delete that language so my
question to you is is why
and my I'll come back with a follow-up
absolutely thank you for your question
and so if I remember the conversation
right about this section although this
is not something I'd follow my sword
over if you want to add it back in I
would be completely fine with that but I
think the reasoning was that we deal
with this in rules uh for the we deal
with it in rules for what is considered
the minor and what is considered a a
moderate type of uh uh incident and it's
more because
rules to a certain extent a little bit
easier process to deal with new
instances and new things that come up
make an open rule making at a drop of a
hat and it goes on for six months in
which case it's presented then to jail
car for the purposes of approving the
new rule so I think the idea was
especially considering the not limited
to language basically says it's anything
anyway there's no read to put a list
into into statute what's the feeling
thank you Senator so
I was wondering whether you had a
specific reason and I'll ask the
question again if I get a chance of the
Lottery Commission I'll ask the same
thing but I would just uh ask this
question as a follow-up it seems to me
that if you read the language after all
of this is eliminated you end up with
three tautologies
so it then leaves you with a minor
violation shall be one dot dot dot where
the harm is
minor
a moderate violation is where the harm
is moderate
and so it seems that we leave it
somewhat unguided and I'm just wondering
if we left this language in would you
have any problem with that as the
sponsor nope not a sword I'd die and
again I think it was because they wanted
to deal with it in rules rather than in
thank you very much
chair recognizes Rick Newman from New
thank you madam chair
Rick Newman representing New Hampshire
charitable gaming operators Association
and we do support the bill and
I understand this committee has passed a
bill to increase the wager limit to 25
and uh the Senate's taken the position
that it should be 50. we obviously
support that this this um
we are in a very competitive environment
as Senator Lang just said
and I mentioned earlier today
in the post-covered world the casinos
around us are ramping up they're they're
doing uh getting back to where they were
uh pre-covered they're doing a lot of uh
promotions a lot of marketing and we see
it
um I passed out
to the committee
uh just a snapshot of for instance state
revenue it's the paper with the blue on
the top and if you look at for instance
March of 2020
I'm sorry 2022
state revenue was 490 000 from uh games
of chance it's table games in poker 490
000. and if you look at March of 23 it
was 5 21. so essentially we're flat we
should be up and the reason I know we
should be up is because in the rooms
that have historic horse racing the
games of chance Revenue has gone up
fairly dramatically
um but for instance in Salem looking at
uh look when I looked at March of this
year versus March of last year Salem
does not have a store course racing yet
and there uh games with chance numbers
were down by about 200 plus thousand
dollars
total revenue so that tells me they're
losing business to the border and that
tells me that that and if you look at
Seabrook the brook
Brooks games are chance numbers are
dramatically up uh because they do have
a store course racing so they've
attracted some business but overall
games of chance are we're fairly flat we
think a 50 wages will do just as Senator
Lang said give us the opportunity to
continue to grow grow money for
Charities and uh obviously help support
our employees
on the rest of the bill one thing I want
to point out because it was in 607 as
well I don't think we took note of it I
just want to make sure you noted it in
uh it's section 15 of this bill it makes
uh it puts into the criminal code
a crime of cheating at charitable gaming
events that's not in the statute as of
now and there are times when people have
been caught cheating but local law
enforcement has been reluctant to
make an arrest because it's not
specifically in the criminal code so
we're that that's the reason that that
thank you
did you want to comment on the question
that representative spilsbury have why
why the change in the whole penalty
description do you know where am I from
my recollection of that is um in fact
the commission that uh or the committee
that representative Ames and abrami were
on received from the lottery several
suggested changes in uh statute that was
one of them so that that really came
from them they wanted more flexibility
to be able to deal with uh penalties for
violations
so that that's really all I know about
would you be open to questions sure
on have you
mixed up the uh
the chair the games of chance state
revenue with the games of chance charity
allocation because we give the Charities
35 percent
so
I'm sorry could you ask that question
again please yeah yeah on just to take
000 uh games of chance charity
allocation one million eight hundred and
twelve right
that's not 35 that's 65 percent
or more
actually it's more than that no that
that seems about right to me actually
it's so if this games of chance state
revenue was 521 000 that would indicate
to me that the total
gross Gaming revenue would have been 5.2
million dollars
the charity should have gotten 35
percent of 5.2 million which off top my
head seems like 1.8 is about right
the charts I've seen from Lottery have
got us taking the LIE and share of that
I thought
I'm sorry I didn't hear you state taking
the 65 so that is on if you go to the
next line over historic horse racing
state revenue
that's just that's just historic horse
racing that's just historic horse racing
that's charitable gaming correctly
okay so that's just historic horse
racing and that is a they are the state
and the charity
are allocated money for historic horse
racing differently than they are for
table games I know but I thought I was
remembering this from from charitable
gaming days when we were a little bit
okay
thank you very much thank you okay I do
not have any other pink cards for Senate
bill 120.
yes
uh I apologize I do not
uh could you get stuck somewhere if you
wait no I found it it was under his
paperwork uh are you Ray
Roy
come on up sorry it was buried Roy
schweiker
welcome to Ways and Means sorry we
foreign
thank you madam chairman members of the
committee I'm Roy schweiker from Concord
I have I guess four General concerns
about this bill number one in the
analysis it says the betting limit on
table Stakes is 2500 but you know in the
bill itself it says however much money
you might have so if you won earlier you
might have more than 2500 and I don't
know if it's legal I haven't found
anything that says it isn't for players
to pool their money so one player might
have you know thousands of dollars so
you know that's just a concern you know
we may be talking even bigger money than
you think number two I'm not quite sure
why if everything is increasing under
this bill
the appropriate people are number one
paying much lower fees and not having to
relicense every year it just seems like
with the increase in money you might
want you know higher fees and more
controls rather than less
the third thing is I'm really concerned
about this you know right now charitable
gaming is kind of charitable gaming you
know people go out and play for the
night you know you can't lose more money
than you might spend going to a major
league sporting event or out to a fancy
restaurant or whatnot but now we're
making it a much larger sum of money
that someone can put in and
you know you could you may attract more
problem gamblers and more organized
crime figures I want to take over but
and they're not going to bother under
the present you know daily limits and so
I feel like let's give the
municipalities an issue some say in here
you know some municipality in the past
has said okay you know we have
charitable gaming so the church can run
bingo games now somebody can come in and
build a casino and they really have no
way of stopping it so I think that you
should allow the municipalities to set
their own limits
you know so long as they're greater than
the ones that exist so that ones that
don't want
big poker players from all over coming
in but only want people to play bingo at
the local church have that opportunity
and in line with that right now once
again there seems to be an issue the
operator essentially sets who what
charities get the money I don't know
that they're limited to New Hampshire
Charities or Charities anybody's ever
heard of they can set up their own
captive Charities so I think maybe also
the municipalities perhaps should be
allowed to limit the Charities that
receive revenue from a
charitable gaming facility to Charities
that
have offices in that particular
community
and lastly once again I'm not quite sure
why you have a bill to approve a
commission to study all this when at the
same time you're making all these
wholesale changes so I'd like to suggest
you table the whole bill and wait until
thank you for joining us today
questions
of course but I don't see any okay thank
okay now I think that is the last card
we have for Senate build 120 is there
anyone else here to speak
oh yes a question of the Lottery
Commission
good morning Valerie King from New
Hampshire Lottery
thank you for taking the question
um same one that I asked Senator Lang
regarding the penalty provisions
if the current law provides specific
examples that illustrate the distinction
between a minor a moderate and a major
violation
and each of those carries a distinctly
different
penalty or fine level
what's the advantage or is there a
specific reason why we should
remove that kind of language and leave
it completely open-ended to rulemaking
yeah so I think that I would uh Echo
Senator Lang in that it's it's
if it were to be left in there would be
no problems it's more of just a
redundancy issue it is further clarified
in rules we set forth a lot more
parameters around when when it reaches a
certain level and examples and in the
rules as well
okay thank you so just to clarify the
rules take these guidelines and expand
upon them but you would see no problem
with keeping this language in the law
great thank you thank you for coming up
could you fill out a pin card just so we
have that too I guess thank you okay now
we will close the public hearing on
Senate Bill 120 and we will now open up
the hearing on Senate Bill 119 relative
to criminal background checks for
charitable games of chance licensed
applicants
uh again for the record I am involved in
this industry and the chair will
recognize
Senator Tim Lang welcome back thank you
members yes I am still a senator even
from this morning so we'll we'll
continue on
um this bill is a pretty straightforward
bill under under current law we have to
do background checks on charitable
gaming
board members if you will
um if you're a charity and you're
participating in charitable gaming we
have background checks on board members
of the charity in and of itself even if
the charity is not participating
directly and just a recipient of the
revenues so the goal is Bill and
speaking with Lottery again is I worked
with Lottery on this this came out of
the Senate Ways and Means unanimously in
the Senate Finance unanimously and on
the floor unanimously
um the idea is we don't need to do
background checks on the charitable
board members the AG has the charitable
trust division that takes care of making
sure that board members and boards are
all okay the only exception is this law
was originally put in because as you
heard before Charities used to do
um you know the the basement bingo games
and poker games and those kind of things
so they're actively involved in
conducting charitable operations
nowadays that's a more of a professional
operation that's taken on by the gaming
operator so it doesn't reduce the gaming
operators from having to have their
background checks it doesn't reduce
people so Charities that are doing like
their own bingo game would still have to
do a background check for the people
involved but it does take away that just
because the boys club and the Girls Club
of Nashua is working with a Nashua
charitable gaming operation all the
board members don't have to have a
criminal background check just because
thank you very much would you be open to
questions absolutely excellent
thank you and you just brought it up on
does it cost more for the operator of a
bingo game that is a single bingo game
for one charity uh to go get the
background checks than it does to
um go higher
a consultant to do it for them
bottle of a consultant can do a
background check on somebody the state
police would do that background check
and criminal check and so that is a
standard last time I had my core reject
done for the school was 25 bucks so
that's the cost to the Charities that
are self-funding and self-running their
own gaming operations they would have to
pay for the people involved
okay so it's still 25 that was the last
time I had it done I don't know if it's
changed
other questions from the committee
members
wow uh thank you thank you very much
okay now this is Senator 119 is I don't
have any other pink cards is there
anyone else yes Valerie would you like
Valerie King New Hampshire lottery I
just wanted to clarify the answer for
representative almi Bingo they are not
required to have a background check
there's no requirement for a background
check for Bingo or Lucky Seven it's only
games of chance
but I think it's 48 dollars
right if it has to be an FBI criminal
background check so it is 48.
okay anything else anyone else in the
audience that would like to speak on
Senate Bill 119 no seeing none we will
close the public hearing
wow you guys did a great job today
that's amazing
okay we'll see see you all tomorrow
morning
what time are we we're 9 30 tomorrow
I think I did something like that
yeah so we have some hearings tomorrow
morning so I look forward to seeing you
all then
my Republican members come meet me
upstairs